Four three, two, one.
And we're live. All right,
so to set this up, um,
when Gary was on last, Gary Tobbs, Stefan,
how do I say your last name? Stephanie.
DNA. DNA. DNA. It's like DNA,
like DNA with a g.
Right. Got It. Okay. Um,
when you were on last, Stephan had, uh,
some opposition to some of the
things that you were saying.
We talked about getting him
on and you want it together.
We finally pulled it off.
Took there was a lot of wrangling was a
lot of back and forth and cat wrangling,
but we got it. We're here. Um,
give me your position on this
is all for folks listening,
this is all about obesity and
the mechanism for obesity.
Is that fair to say?
Yeah.
So essentially the main points
that we want to talk about today,
I'll try to keep this up just from your
face. Okay, sure. Just so you move around,
um, what causes obesity and
what causes insulin resistance,
which is behind a lot of our chronic
diseases that are common in society.
And please, uh, give us
your background. Yeah.
So I have a
bs in biochemistry,
Phd in neuroscience.
After getting my phd in neuroscience,
I went on to study the neuroscience of
obesity at the University of Washington
in particularly the brain circuits
that regulate body fatness.
Hopefully we'll get a chance
to talk about those today.
And then I went on to become a science
consultant at science communicator and
write a book called the
hungry brain. That is, um,
my attempt to explain for a non
specialist audience what, uh,
what causes obesity and uh,
yeah, so that's my background.
Now, what is your disagreement
with Gary's position? Everything.
Everything. Yeah. So, uh,
how about, how about I just,
can I start by explaining what I believe
because it'd be saying I'm going to be
long winded here. Is that okay?
Go right ahead. All right.
We have ours. Okay, cool.
So first,
a little bit of housekeeping.
I'm going to be citing a lot of evidence
today and so I want these bringing this
up to your focus. Sure. Just moving
around. Sure. If you want to sit back.
How's that? Perfect. Okay.
I'm going to be citing a lot of evidence
today and I want people to be able to
follow along at home.
And so I put many of the references that
I'm going to be siting on that so it
doesn't cover your face.
Okay, there we go. All right.
I put a lot of the references that I'm
going to be siting on my website Stephin
bna.com or if you don't
feel like spelling my name,
you can go to whole health source.org and
I have a numbered list of topics there
and I'm going to be calling out numbers.
Just scroll down to the number that I
referred to and the references are all
there.
The second thing I want to say that I
would want to be really clear about today
is that I'm not here to be the
anti low carb guy. Okay. Um,
I think low carb diets are valid
tool for a controlling body,
fatness and controlling blood sugar.
I'm not here to talk anybody out
of being on a low carb diet. Um,
what I am here to try to
talk people out of this.
Some of the mythology that has
accumulated around the low carb diet.
Okay, so I want to get started with an
analogy to help people understand, um,
why the brain is important and obesity.
So imagine you're an alien coming
down from outer space and you want to
understand what's going on on earth and
you notice that on the highway some cars
are traveling faster than others.
Some cars go faster,
some cars go slower and
you want to figure out why.
And so you go and you start studying the
tires of the cars because obviously the
amount of force that is exerted by the
tire onto the asphalt is the thing that
determines the speed of the car.
We know this, this is just physics.
And so you study the tires and you study
the tires and you study them and you
never figure out why some cars go
faster than others. Now why is that?
The reason is that you're studying
the wrong part of the system.
You want to understand the why.
Some cars go faster than others.
You have to understand the part of
the system that regulates speed,
and that is the person behind the wheel.
And so in this analogy,
the tires are fat cells and the
person behind the wheel is the brain.
There has been tons of research on fat
cell biology on what factors put fat in
fat cells,
what take it out.
It's been tons and tons of research on
that and it's intuitively obvious that we
should be studying that to understand
obesity, right? But in fact,
all of that research has yielded very
little insight into why some people are
fatter than others. That's because
it's the wrong part of the system.
Study fat cells do not regulate the size
of fat cells any more than the tires on
a car regulate the speed of the car.
The thing that regulates the size of fat
cells is the brain. So let's talk about,
um, first of all, give you a little
framework for thinking about this.
The brain evolved over about 600 million
years to promote the survival and
reproduction of our ancestors.
And over the course of that time we
evolved all of these different brain
circuits that have specialized functions.
They generate our hunger and our
cravings and our fullness feelings.
They generate our eating behavior,
what and how much we eat.
And they actively regulate the
amount of fat on our bodies.
And that's one of the
things I want to talk about.
And all of these circuits evolved.
And these are nonconscious by the way.
So you don't decide.
You want to be hunger,
you don't decide that you
want to have a craving.
These are things that bubble up from
nonconscious parts of your brain that you
don't control. So, um,
these circuits are calibrated to
an environment of our ancestors,
not the environment where
we're living in right now.
So these circuits all evolved to function
optimally in the environment of our
ancestors, promote the survival
and reproduction of our ancestors.
So,
um,
what happens when you put these brain
circuits in the modern environment where
you have abundant calorie,
dense, tasty foods,
rich and carbohydrate and fat is these
same brain circuits push us to over
consume and they push our bodies
to accumulate and hold onto fat.
And then what you see as a result
is the three hallmarks of obesity.
First of all, the obvious, you see
elevated body fat mass. Second of all,
you see elevated calorie intake.
People with obesity consume more calories
than people who do not have obesity
after correcting for height and
sex and physical activity level.
And third,
you see that people with obesity defend
their higher level of body fatness
against changes. And so there's actually
a regulatory change that happens.
It's not conscious defense,
you know,
they're not trying to remain obese.
It's these body fat regulatory circuits.
And this is where Gary gets it right,
is that people with obesity are not
just lean. People who eat more calories.
There's actually a change
in the regulatory activity
that regulates body fat in
the body.
And we can get back to how that happens.
But I'll just leave it there for now.
So up until this point,
I've basically just been telling
a plausible story, right? I mean,
I haven't actually cited any
evidence yet to support that.
My story is correct. Um,
and so let's get into that.
Let's talk about what some of the evidence
is that supports this idea that I've
just laid out. So I
want to start with, um,
the genetics of obesity.
I think this offers some wait,
can I interrupt for one second?
Uh, as long as it's very brief,
the question I don't, I still don't
quite understand what the model is. Okay.
This regulation,
if you don't understand the model,
how about I lay out,
how about I finish laying it out and
then you can ask a question because I may
answer your question over the
course of a continuing. So let me,
let me just finish. Um, okay.
So now the genetics of obesity offers
us a lot of insight into the biological
mechanisms that drive differences in
body fatness in the general population.
So you get these studies,
like the,
the most interesting studies are
the genome wide association studies.
They get hundreds of thousands
of people together and they, um,
sequence or they,
they measure all these markers in their
genomes and they figure out what parts
of the genome makes some
people fatter than another.
So if you have version a in
this particular location,
you end up a little fatter
than if you have version B.
And when you look at all the
places where this is happening,
you can see the genes where it's
happening in. And that tells you,
if you look at what those genes are doing,
that tells you what the mechanisms are
that underlie every day differences in
body, in the general population.
And so to kind of warm ourselves up,
let's start by talking about height genes.
So height has a strong genetic component,
so it was body fatness and researchers
has figured out a lot of the genes that
underlie differences in
height between people.
And when you look at what those genes do,
they tend to be involved in the growth
and development of the skeleton and the
connective tissue, which is
what you would expect, right?
Cause growth of the skeleton
determines your height.
So genes that determine diabetes risk
type two diabetes are all about insulin
sensitivity,
all about insulin secretion
and the function of the
insulin secreting pancreas,
which is what you expect because
diabetes is a disease that is all about
insulin. So these studies are really good
at getting at the underlying biological
mechanisms that are
driving these phenomena.
So what do these studies
have to say about obesity?
If Gary's model is correct,
we should see a bunch of genes popping
up related to fat cells and insulin.
If my model is correct,
we should see a bunch of genes popping
up related to the brain. And in fact,
that's exactly what we see.
The genetics of obesity are overwhelmingly
related to differences in brain
activity between individuals and um,
okay,
so that's one piece of evidence.
Another piece of evidence.
There are five FDA
approved weight loss drugs.
Four of those act in the brain.
One of them reduces dietary fat
absorption in the digestive tract.
There are no effective fat loss drugs
and I'm aware of the target insulin and
fat cells. Third piece of
evidence. Um, if you look at,
some people get really unlucky in life
and they end up with these horrible
genetic mutations that, you know,
knock out some biological pathways.
Some of these people end up with
extreme obesity people and also animals.
We see this in mice and rats.
Just occasionally you get unlucky
and you get really, really fat.
And researchers have been cataloguing.
What are these mutations?
When we find people who are
genetically really obese,
what are these mutations
that are making them fat?
What is the biological mechanism that's
getting screwed up that's making them
fat?
And what they've found is that all of
these mutations that they've identified to
date,
a number of them are occurring
in the Leptin signaling pathway.
And this is the Leptin,
um,
is the primary fat regulating
hormone in the body.
Gary avoids this,
never talks about this in his writing,
but Leptin is the primary fat
regulating hormone in the body.
And these mutations
either knock out Leptin,
they knock out leptin receptors or they
knock out the left and response pathway
in the brain. And um, so that's
the third piece of evidence.
Okay.
So now we haven't really gotten around
to talking about what it exactly about
the bad interaction that happens between
our ancient brains and the modern food
environment that causes us to become fat.
Um,
we've established that the
brain is central to obesity,
but we haven't really established what
it is exactly about that interaction.
Why does our modern food, why does our
modern environment promote obesity?
Right?
So I'm basically,
there are three different ways that
I'm going to look at this from,
um,
but first I want to say that the,
probably the best way to answer this
question is to start with the question,
what is the most fattening
diet in the world?
What is the Diet that is more
fattening than any others?
And the answer to that is it's human junk
food in a variety of non human species
and humans. It's human junk food that
is more fattening than any others.
And I'm going to skip over some of the
research here, um, that demonstrates this.
By the way, I haven't been
calling out numbers here. Okay.
Let me call out some numbers.
Um,
reference number two on my website is,
um,
those genetic studies.
Reference number one is the obesity drugs.
Reference number six is those
spontaneously occurring genetic mutations?
And now I'm talking about reference
number 52. So I'm, I'm gonna,
I'm gonna Gloss over some
of the individual research
cause I'm being long winded
here.
But um,
essentially what you find is that this
stuff is really fattening and animals,
many different species. It's super
fattening and humans calorie dense.
When you put create an environment
with abundant easy calorie, dense,
tasty foods,
rich carbs and fat,
you see this dramatic overconsumption in
fact game across many species including
humans.
And what you find in the research is that
the sugar and the carbohydrate cannot
explain that they're part of the
effect. Yes, they explained part of it.
But you cannot replicate that effect
by only feeding sugar and carbohydrate.
You can't replicate it in animals.
You can't replicate it in humans.
When you say you can't replicate it,
you mean you can't replicate obesity?
What do you mean? Yeah. Um,
that's right. You cannot,
you cannot cause the
same degree of fat gain,
the same extent of fat gain,
the same extent of overconsumption using
only sugar and carbohydrate that you
can cause with a variety of calorie dense,
palatable human foods. You can't fully
replicate it with sugar and carbs.
You cannot fully replicate
it with fat alone either.
If you put those when we can,
we can get deeper in this if you want,
but I'm confused. So you're,
you're saying that the,
the Diet that causes the most
obesity is what we think, right?
This a human junk food diet in
sugar, simple carbs, bullshit,
bullshit diet, right. What do you,
you're saying that you can't replicate
that with just your arms slowly
replicated fully and so it's,
what I mean is that if you just feed,
if you just increase sugar
intake in animals or in humans,
you do get weight gain,
but it is modest compared to what you
get when you put people around a variety
of calorie dense, palatable foods,
rich and carbohydrate and fat.
Similarly, if you, that's
very confusing. How's that?
Because I'm not sure exactly what
you're saying. You're saying you,
if you give people this calorie
rich sugar diet of junk food,
you will make them gain weight
but not as much weight as what?
Um,
so what I'm saying is that if you,
if you give people or animals the,
the actual human junk food with all
the carbs and fat and everything,
they gain a lot more weight and a lot
faster than if you just give them a diet
that's high in sugar and
high in refined carbohydrate.
And what that shows is that the sugar and
they're fine carbohydrate cannot fully
explain the effect. Can't fully
explain why those foods are fattening.
See this is where I'm confused. No, I
don't see what you're saying cause you're,
you're saying if you give people
the Diet of American junk food,
you,
you get not as much of an effect if
you give them just the sugar and the
carbohydrates, you're saying? Yep. So,
but what are you giving them when you're
giving them the, the Diet of junk food,
you give her a 10 for example,
in animals now it's different because
if you think about human junk foods,
generally those foods contain fat and
carbohydrate and salt and all kinds of
other things. So it's more,
it's more than just let's a lot,
so carbs and sugar.
So I'll get in more detail.
So the ways that you can do this,
you can add sugar,
just sugar table sugar to the feed
of animals. That's one way to do it.
Or you can add it to their drinking water.
Sometimes it's a little bit fattening,
sometimes it's not. It's not that
fattening and animals and humans,
you can ask them to drink sugar sweetened
beverages that are just sugar and you
can see what happens and people will
gain weight or you can tell them to stop
drinking sugar sweetened beverages
and you can see what happens. Okay.
People will gain weight,
they will lose weight suggesting
that that is part of the explanation,
but it's a much smaller effect than you
see with this full pallet of these foods
that contain carbs and fat and all this
other stuff that you're saying car.
Well obviously there's more calories,
right?
If there's carbs and fat and
all these other, correct.
If you think that calories matter, then
we agree. Oh, for short matters, right?
Gary doesn't think it matters. You don't
think it matters. Well, let me think.
It's the wrong way to think about it.
What,
what do you disagree if anything
with what he said so far? Well,
so far what he said,
it hasn't been particularly
revenue. Latori um, the, uh,
I think we have to step back
for a second because you know,
while the low carb community might have
a more better understanding of where we
disagree,
um,
I think the greater community that Joe
Reaches might not so fundamentally with
Stefan saying and what the research
community saying and the conventional
thinking in this field is that the brain,
and correct me any point I get this wrong,
but the brain regulates,
does the fundamental job of controlling
how fast we are and the way it does it
is by controlling or miss controlling
our intake and our expenditure and the
different tents up in fat tissue.
Is that fair to say for the most
primarily intake but yet, yeah.
So Stefan has a brain centric view of
the universe and the car community at
large does as well. So if we go
outside and we walked down, you know,
Ventura Boulevard and we see
someone who weighs 400 pounds,
um,
they've clearly taken in more calories
than they should have over the course of
their life.
And it's been stored in their fat tissue.
And Stefan says,
I think would say that the problem is in
their brains ability to regulate intake
to expenditure. Is that
correct? Yeah. Okay.
And let me, I have to fix my headphones.
So how are we going to do this?
I'm getting feedback when I talk. You
getting feedback? Yeah, it's just weird.
It could be the,
hold on one sec.
For those who don't know,
I'm hearing impaired as they say kindly.
My kids would say deaf as a post,
so I took off my hearing aids
and it's a little better. Okay.
So what I've been arguing, so I come
along my background, I'm a journalist,
I'm an investigative journalist
with a science background.
Okay. That's what I do.
And I'm curious and I've got
a lot of, you know, and I,
my first two books were studying
what's called pathological science,
which is about people who've got the
wrong results in science because a lot of
times scientists do so by,
I'm very sensitive to this.
And as I was doing the
research for my first book,
which took five years,
what I noticed in when you
take a historical perspective
is that the research
community studying obesity
was very focused on the brain.
They just assume that that people are
gluttons and I'm going to use some
socially unacceptable, uh,
language because in part
that's how they thought about.
And in fact, when you read
the, uh, obesity literature
from the forties and 50s,
it's shocking the way these people
talked about people with obesity.
And the assumption was
that they're gluttons are,
they're neurotic or they're anxious
or they're just, you know, but,
but it was all brain center.
And when they go out to the 1960s,
the field was being run by psychologists
and psychiatrists who are trying to get
people with obesity eat less.
And it,
my favorite example is one team
that was trying to get they,
they got the wives to stop having sex
with the husband if they didn't lose
weight every week.
And now with motivate them,
I think even you point out that sex
is a greater motivator in your book.
Then tasty foods.
It didn't say it was greater but I
said it was on par or on par. So,
and I'm going to just read you a,
I won't read you that the,
so there was this, while the
obesity research community
is focusing on the brain,
there were people studying fat
metabolism and an endocrinologist.
They studied hormones and hormone related
disorders saying that the oh you know,
fat storage and fat mobilization,
the burning of fat and the human body is
controlled by this very diverse set of
hormones and enzymes and the nervous
system is involved in well and our body
does a very careful job of deciding
basically orchestrating how
we use fields after we eat.
And the implication was,
and I think Stefan kind of stepped into
this with the very first thing you said.
So the assumption was obesity is a
disorder of excess fat accumulation.
So today when you read the literature,
the articles we'll opposite.
Obesity is a sort of energy imbalance.
You take in more calories
than they expend.
There were still the best
scientists in the field,
the best physician scientist
with they look obesity,
a sort of excess fat accumulation. Let's
look at what regulates fat accumulation.
The human body.
Some people are programmed or dysregulated
to store more fat and if the store
more fat, they're going to, their
behavior is going to respond,
they'll be hungry or they'll eat more,
there'll be gluttons, all these things.
So it was a switching the causality
instead of the brain determining energy
balance and that determining
fat accumulation.
The idea was sort of, let's see,
what regulates fat accumulation.
If that's dysregulated,
if I have a,
if I give birth to a daughter who weighs
a hundred pounds at age four I'm not
going to worry about how
much he eats and exercises.
I'm going to worry about what's going
on with fat accumulation and this young
girl that her body is just
as if you give a, you know,
if you have a child who's six foot
eight when he was six years old,
you're not going to worry about
how much he eats an exercises.
You're going to worry that he's over
secreting growth hormone. So the idea,
basically what I've done,
my role in this is to say look
in this vitally important period in the
1960s and 1970s when obesity researchers
came to understand fat
metabolism researchers came
to understand that regulation
of fat cells,
the obesity people were convinced
that the problem was in the brain.
And those obesity people eventually grew
into the world that Stefan got his PhD
in neuro biological world where you study
what's happening in the brain and you
ignore what's happening in the fat cells
and fat mobilization and fatty acid
oxidation and tad Stuart.
And when you look at that,
you find a whole world of places in
which people can pre be predetermined,
you know, be driven to
be fat. So, for example,
when I was in high school,
senior year in high school,
I weighed 195 pounds and I played
football and my brother two years older,
weight 195 pounds his senior
year and played football.
My brother never got more than 195
pounds and I went up to two 40.
We both ate as much as humanly possible.
You know, as you could imagine,
that's what high school athletes do.
My brother was always a lien.
I was always chubby. My brother stayed
lean and became an endurance athlete.
I became a football player
and I lifted weights.
I put on muscle easily and I
fattened easily. He didn't.
Um,
the conventional wisdom
would be the reason I went
to two 40 and he never got to
one 95 was that my brain
was different than his.
My argument is our bodies
were fundamentally different.
So if I see somebody walking down
the street or weighs 300 pounds,
I don't worry about,
I don't think about what the problem
is with her brain regulating intake and
expenditure.
I think about what's,
why is her body driving her to be
300 pounds? So that's, I think,
kind of the fundamental
difference. Um, and is it,
is it the brain that can't do the job
or is it the body that can't do the job
and the brain is responding to
what's happening in the body?
Yeah. Is this a reductionist perspective?
Cause I mean, isn't it a holistic,
I mean holistically you're looking at
the entire machine of the human body.
The idea that the brain is somehow or
another separate from the body is saying
it's separate.
The question is,
is a brain driving what's happening in
the body or is it responding to whatever?
Um,
and you know,
the brain of course does respond a lot
to what's happening in the body and we
can talk about that and how that
works. Um, but you know, I think it's,
we can tell stories,
but the things,
the thing that differentiates a story
that's true from a story that is not true
is evidence. And so, you know,
you talk about the difference
between your brother and you.
This is where that genetics evidence comes
back in that I was talking about your
brother and you only
share half of your genes.
We know that genetics has a strong impact
on who has a greater susceptibility to
body fatness and not than others.
And we also know what the genes do that
underlie those differences and they are
primary. I'm not done Gary, let me
finish those genes. Those genes. Nope.
Nope, not right now. I'm in
the middle of saying something.
Those genes are primarily related
to differences in brain function.
That is what the genetic say.
And so that suggests that the reason why
you had a greater propensity than your
brother to become fat probably has to
do with differences in genetics that
relate to brain function. That
is what the research says. Okay,
very actually look when you talked
about two 17 year olds that way,
exactly the same amount. Like how do we
know how much they consumed in calories?
I mean, we don't have any
studies. We don't have any,
I mean I can guarantee you we both paid
as much as humanly possible. Right?
But I'm actually my brother who never
got over one 95 and I apologize for
bringing you up on the air.
I know you don't like that used
to say that he never gets stuffed.
He just gets bored of eating after
a couple of hours. Okay, okay.
But I mean that'd be even though like
maybe if you looked at it scientifically,
you ate more than him or maybe
you ate more sugar, more carbs.
So that's a difference. So the, those
are the two hypothesis. One hypothesis is
my body and this is what Stefan is
talking about. So I want to just,
the thing I wanted to read, how
much, I'll ask you the question,
how much of the variation in human
obesity to those genes explain?
So if you look at the genetics of that,
I didn't ask how much
let's talking. Yeah, you
got to look to please Gary.
So if you look at the genetics of obesity,
what you find is that from twin studies
and family studies that measure the
overall contribution of genetics,
about 75% of the differences in body
fatness between individuals is due to
genetic differences between
those individuals. So, you know,
1995 America,
if you just take a cross section of
people and you measure how much is genes,
how much is environment,
about 75% is genetic.
Now we've only identified
a small proportion of the
specific genes that underlie
the propensity to obesity.
And so if you look at the percentage
that we have specifically identified,
it's a very small, and that's what I
refer to in my book. How much it's like a,
right now I think it's up to about 10%
it was 3% when your book was published.
That's correct. And they
did 7% absolutely. Yeah.
The latest. Yeah. Actually,
let me cite the, uh, so while
the study, they're just a second,
I'm going to cite this study just a
second. I'm gonna cite this study. Uh,
this study is under reference number two.
So you can,
you can go check that out.
It's about 10% and these genetic
studies are advancing very quickly.
And that's why in the three
years since I wrote that,
we have explained a lot more than we
did at the time that I wrote that.
And so we have a portion of these genes
identified and what we're seeing is that
most of that portion that we have
identified relate to brain activity.
And so that tells us that primarily the
differences between individuals that
determined differences in body.
And this is about
differences in brain activity.
And no one should be shocked about this.
The brain generates all
of our eating behavior.
It generates all of our physical activity
behavior and it actually regulates
body fatness. No one should
be surprised by this. I am.
And I was.
And how were you surprised you again?
Now if you disagree with virtually
everything, but, um, let's begin with
track back now. The um, okay,
so drugs that explain obesity 10% with
the argument that I was making and the
argument I continued to make. Imagine
if you don't, we'll take Stefan's,
uh, car medicine's Stefan.
He says, Steph. Okay.
It's okay. I'm not saying that, but I
mean that people don't get confused.
Thank you.
The,
if you take Stephan's car analogy
and somewhere in the 1970s, I,
I've used the car analogy for this too,
but I don't think it's as appropriate.
But one way to think that
somewhere in the 1970s,
the aliens didn't notice that
there were humans driving the car.
So now they're trying to solve the
problem without the humans involved. Well,
I see some cars drive faster than others
and they come up with all kinds of
hypotheses and some of them can
explain it even when they interpret the
hypotheses.
One of the common problems and science
has called intellectual face lock.
So what I've been arguing is in effect
the obesity research community left out
of its research,
1960s era endocrinology,
the hormonal metabolic regulation
of fatty acid metabolism,
oxidation burning.
And it sucks when they did it.
Pretty much everything they've done
since has been interpreted incorrectly.
Just like the aliens would interpret
the car problem if they never notice the
humans. So, um, and
Leptin is a good example.
So Leptin is discovered in 1993
and when Leptin is discovered,
obesity becomes sort of a legitimate
field of science. Until then,
it's a bunch of actually
mostly psychologists studying
it and now it becomes a
subdiscipline and molecular biology and
all the molecular just jump into the
field and they assume that would let them,
does,
is controlled the brain signals how
much fat is available to some kind of
satiety or field efficiency
[inaudible] hormone.
And as such,
they studied the brain and they studied
the action of Lipton in the brain.
Now in 2002,
Jeff Friedman who gets credit for
discovering Leptin perhaps incorrectly,
um,
publishes a paper in the journal Science.
It's saying perhaps as much as two thirds
or more of what Leptin does is done in
the periphery in the body.
And what Leptin does,
it's a hormone that sort of is,
is secreted in response to how
much fat you've accumulated.
And then does it stimulate the brain to
tell you to eat more or less depending
on how much fat or it
also works in liver cells,
which are the cells that were studying.
And the assumption is it probably doesn't
all cells to tell yourselves to burn
fat.
So it makes perfect sense if there's fat
available in the fat cell is now you've
got a signal telling sort of influencing
the other cells of the body to burn fat.
So now you've got a hormone that
could work in the periphery, in the,
in the below then neck or it
could work above the neck.
But you've got a community that to
almost exclusively studying in the head.
They don't know they're a human drivers
down here. So that's what they do.
So even in this world,
the, the I, I don't,
I think I know the genome paper I'm
Stefan is probably referenced on,
that's the reason. Is it
the, I don't remember the,
so they had two papers cause it's what
you cited in the article you coauthored
with Rudy Leibel.
So I have two papers.
One is genes associated with obesity and
one is genes associated with body type.
So with body type, they're all below
the neck. They're all, you know,
fat metabolism basically.
And the Musk,
the genes at aspects of your body that
you would expect to be controlled.
Like when you build up muscle and you
have to take an excess energy to do it.
It makes you hungry.
I don't think your brain is regulating
how much muscle you're building other
than your drive to go to the gym.
Basically your body is responding
to the stress on the muscle,
all the things you do and the
weightlifting. It's all below the neck.
So the argument here is again simple.
When these people looked at body type,
it was insulin regulated
genes for the most part,
growth hormone, all of these things.
When they looked at excess body fat,
they decided they were in the head.
But the question is when they looked their
program to think that excess body fat,
it's caused by overeating.
So they look in the brain.
Did they do the same kind and I was
going to call the researcher involved.
I never got around to doing it.
Saying if body type body
shape is determined by these
genes and it doesn't make
sense that x has variations of body shape,
we're going to be determined
by the same genes.
And did you just do the
same kind of searches?
I don't actually know how they
determine where the genes work.
It's the same kind of searches. They just
came up with different sets of genes.
So they didn't start with any assumptions.
They were just finding the
questionnaire where the genes work.
So there's a common phenomenon.
All this like with Leptin,
a gene that everybody thinks about working
in the hypothalamus seems to work and
everything. Can I respond to that
talking cause you say this in your head,
you say this in your book. Go ahead. I'm
prepared to respond whenever you're done.
Okay. In your book you say that gene's
work you, the body is very, basically,
it puts a different mechanisms
to work as many places that can.
And there these homeostatic feedback
loops, you know, something happens.
Your whole body has to respond.
So a gene that my work primarily on
one cell is scattered all over the body
because every cell, and it'll do
different jobs on different cells.
But if you think that the problems
in the brain, that's where you look,
you said you get this kind of intellectual
phase lock where that's what we do.
That's what we study. And
neurobiologists studies the brain. Uh,
uh,
Daniel Conaman,
I just stepped in like suicide Daniel
Economy and as well had this concept.
What you see is all, he's a Nobel
laureate, uh, cognitive psychologists.
What you see is all there is.
Okay.
And basically if you're
studying the brain,
that's what you look at if you're studying
the gun until we all get trapped into
that on some extent. And what I'm
saying is, even in these studies,
so Stefan,
Stefan wrote a book about the hungry brain
that is supposed to be about obesity,
but in fact,
you never mentioned anything about the
metabolic regulation of fat accumulation.
It's just not there.
And I would argue it has to be there.
Even if it's wrong, if it's
not there, the absence of it.
Like you can't talk about Leptin without
talking about what it might be doing in
the body. You can talk, you
know, so there's a the end,
it's put me in a very odd position.
So Stephan is kind of the defender of
the Orthodox and I'm the one who comes
along and says, look, you guys
just, you missed it. You screwed up.
You had psychologists and psychiatrists
running the field when the
endocrinologist sob that and then
you discovered Leptin and it became a
molecular biology problem and you're
now divorced from the very simplest
observations about obesity.
You know,
so we can do huge genome
wide association studies.
A sound remarkable.
But if I were to ask a simple question
like why is it I get fat here?
Yeah, the love handle thing, it's in the
back with man. It's not in the front,
but it's here and not here.
I don't see what the brain has
to say about that. Um, okay. So,
as you mentioned,
there have been different genetic
studies that have looked at body fat
distribution versus total body fatness.
So total body fat,
and this is what we're talking about
when we're talking about obesity. Uh,
body fat distribution is what we're
talking about when we're talking about the
fat being on your hips
versus on your wrist.
Now what we see is different
sets of genes that come up.
So body fat distribution,
we actually see insulin,
a related genes, so people that have
a central body fat distribution,
so body fat around their waist tend to
have these insulin related genes that are
driving that.
But when you look at total body fatness,
the thing that causes obesity,
what you see is that those genes
are dominated by the brain.
And the really cool thing,
the point I want to make
about the genetics research
10% is that it seems might
be dominated by the brain
if say, look, come on Gary.
It is unbiased. That's the really cool
thing about it is that they're just,
this is whatever genes are popping up.
These studies do not care about what
you believe about what causes obesity.
This is just whatever
genes are popping up.
So it's unbiased and that's what they're
saying and I'm not done here. Gary.
Now I want to talk about,
um, you mentioned Gary,
that maybe Leptin is
having important actions,
not just in the brain but in the
body. First of all, I'm glad,
I'm flattered that you read my book
and I'm glad that you acknowledge the
existence of Leptin. Now this is good. Um,
but now you say that researchers focus
on Leptin actions in the brain because
we're phase locked and we
can't get out of our, you know,
blinders of thinking about it in terms
of the brain and that that's why we focus
on left an action in the brain.
The real reason we focus on left in
action in the brain is because it has been
demonstrated that it's effect on body.
Fatness are via the brain.
There are actual experiments
demonstrating this,
and I'll explain how
these experiments work.
This is all in the scientific literature.
So if you knock out the Leptin receptor
only in the brain or only in the
Hypothalamus,
you get obesity.
So that is what tells us that actually
the brain is the key site of action.
And particularly this challenge.
It tells me Gary Key site,
please let him talk.
He let you talk. Yeah. And that's it.
So I mean you get the same obesity if
you knock leaped and how to the brain and
particularly out of the hypothalamus
that you get if you knock it out of the
whole body.
So that shows that the brain is this
site of action that is causing this to
happen. And this is no surprise. We
have these mechanisms worked out.
We know specific groups of neurons that
are receiving the left and that are
controlling our appetite,
that are controlling our metabolic rate.
We have many of these neuro
populations worked out in mice.
We understand these systems so well.
We can control specific popular tiny
populations of neurons very precisely.
Caused them to eat a ton,
to stop eating, to gain fat,
to lose fat like the
animals are marionettes.
I mean that's the level of understanding
we have right now of how these systems
work.
So I mean all of this evidence
is converging on the same
thing that the brain is
central and that fat cell metabolism,
I'm just not seeing the
evidence for that. I mean, Gary,
if you want to cite specific evidence
demonstrating that that is an actual cause
of differences in body fatness between
individuals in the general population.
I'm awaiting that evidence and I'm happy
to sit here and listen to you cite the
evidence that demonstrates. Can I, can I
pause here and Leptin is produced where?
Yeah, Leptin is produced. Yeah.
Let's talk about Leptin a little bit.
It's produced in fat cells and it's
produced in proportion to the size of fat
tissue. So the amount of body fat
you have, the more fat you have,
the more Leptin you have in the
circulation. And basically what this is,
it's what's called a
negative feedback loop,
which is a really simple engineering
term that works like a thermostat.
So with your Thermostat,
you uh,
if you set your thermostat to 70, if it
starts getting a little bit of hotter,
your ac turns on to bring it back
down at the starts getting lower,
ac comes on or the heat
comes on to bring it up.
That's called a negative feedback system
and it maintains the stability of the
temperature of your house.
We have many negative feedback loops
in the human body to regulate body
temperature, to regulate blood pressure,
to regulate all sorts of things.
One of the negative feedback loops we
have regulates body fatness and the
hormones. So your, your
thermostat measures temperature
by using a thermostat,
a Saria,
a thermometer,
your brain measures body fatness using
this hormone leptin that's in the
circulation. And then particularly
when your body fat level drops,
your Leptin levels drop and your brain
hears that and it kicks in a starvation
response basically.
And this is the main reason why weight
loss is so difficult because your brain
is like, no, I don't want to be
losing fat. And it makes you hungrier.
It increases your cravings. Yes. Is that
a certain level of body fat as a sub.
So here's this, just when you're
losing body fat in general,
like even if you're a large
person that's overweight, correct.
When you're losing body fat in general,
your body, it exacerbates your hunger.
And this is,
this is the thing that's really important
to understand about obesity is that
people with obesity
have a higher set point.
So it's like turning your thermostat from
70 to 80 and then your thermostats of
regulating around 80 people with obesity,
they're not regulating
around one 70 anymore.
They're regulating around two 50 and
so when you cause a lean person to lose
weight,
you see the same thing is when you cause
a person with obesity to lose weight,
you see this reaction in their brain
circuits that regulate body fatness that
drives them to increase their cravings
and their hunger to metabolic rate drops.
So it'd be an evolutionary mechanism
to force you to seek food. Correct.
And not just the foresee to seek food.
That's the main thing.
But it also slows your metabolic rate,
does everything it can to
get more energy in your body.
And have less leaving and it keeps
doing that until the fat comes back.
Can I pause here?
Yeah.
So when you're eating a sugary
die at a high high calorie diet,
you will produce more fat. Your
body will get fatter, right? Um,
it depends on how many calories
you're eating. If you're overeating,
you consuming a lot of sugar, a lot of
carbohydrates, your body will get fatter.
So your body will produce more
Leptin. Correct. So it comes from the
um, yeah, indirectly,
definitely pause, please.
So the Leptin is produced not just in
response to the size of the fat tail,
but in response actually to glucose and
a mediated uptake into the fat cell,
which is mediated in part by insulin.
So you come back to insulin,
even with the Leptin, you raise
blood sugar and that's the carbs.
You eat the carbs, you raise blood sugar,
you raise insulin, you raise fat storage,
the glucose, and then you get
more leaped. And um, again,
one of the things you have to understand
about this is everything that's said
has two interpretations, depending
on which paradigm you're looking in.
And these are fundamentally
different paradigms.
So in Stephen's world, and again,
correct me if I'm wrong though,
the Leptin is signaling
few all availability in the
fat cells the way I would
think of it.
And in my very small world and Leptin is
responding to fuel availability in the
rest of the cells.
So it's basically a molecule that
can tell other cells that there's fat
available and you could burn that fat for
fuel and then you don't have to go eat
or it can tell that there
isn't fuel available. And if,
depending on how much left in there is
the cells and then that what respond by a
signal to eat or not to
disinhibit eating behavior. Um,
everything we're talking about with Stefan
and I first sort of fell out, I dunno,
eight years ago at
ancestral health symposium when I
acted improperly inappropriately.
But one of the problems I had to,
the way I think you should think
about this, you have a hypothesis,
and this is the fundamental thing,
is it obesity caused by overeating?
Because we know if you're getting fatter,
you're storing more calories in your
expense. That's just the, you know,
that's like if a room is getting more
crowded, more people are entering them.
Leaving.
That is the simplest,
but it doesn't tell you why
the room's getting crowded.
It doesn't tell you why you're
getting fatter. And again,
what I've been arguing is the
why you're getting fatter.
Part has been left out and people
decided that overeating was somehow an
explanation and then they went to the
brain to look at white people might
overeat. So what I, one of the questions
I asked to find eight years ago,
and it keeps coming up as if we're going
to blame obesity on the modern food
environment, epidemics
of obesity, you know,
simple question to ask is can we find
epidemics of obesity without this modern
food environment? I mean, that's
the sort of science one o one right?
And it turns out that
the world is following.
The first one I found in the literature
was in 1902 in a population of the Pima
native American tribes, pm and living
in Arizona and observers saying,
these people are poor,
they're malnourished, they're
suffering through famines,
they've been suffering through a
famine for 40 years and famines.
It's hard to overeat during a famine.
And yet the women of the tribe who do
virtually all the work that they were
treated as pack animals and effect,
we're obese.
So now we can disassociate obesity from
the modern food environment and we could
disassociated from,
uh,
this ultra processed foods we eat
and start to ask the question,
what is it about,
can we find what might have driven
obesity in that population despite the
existence of famine?
So it's from very simple observation.
Once we get into these kinds of studies,
say this in human genome studies,
say that,
um,
I actually rarely do that in my books
because you can find studies that will say
anything and you'll see in the studies,
um,
people misinterpreting them.
What was the cause of the population
of women to be obese? Well.
So one of the thing that happened
during the Vint beginning in the 1860s,
the PMO were put on a reservoir.
They moved on to reds or
they were reservation eyes
whenever the verb form would
be.
And they began eating western foods.
And back then it was sugar flour and lard
for the most part and sugary beverages
probably.
So that's a reasonable hypothesis.
And you could find the same thing.
And the Sioux native American sue
population living on a reservation in 1928
where you had uh,
oh both obese men and women
living with malnourished,
stunted children who clearly
wouldn't getting enough diet,
but they were on a reservation, they
were getting western foods. So ultimately
the question you ask in science
determines the answer you get.
So the question I was asking is we have
this observation that any population
that transitions to western diet or
western diet and lifestyle gets obese and
diabetic, they, they develop
what's called Metabolic Syndrome,
which is insulin resistance
and all these issues.
And we know that's true
all over the world.
From the [inaudible] to the
Pima to south Pacific islanders,
to Africans, to European. So the
genetics aren't that important.
The question is what's triggering it
in the environment and against Stephan
would say,
well there's too much food available and
it's too palatable and we can't say no.
And I had a lot of problems with the,
we can say no part cause if we're lean
it means that they can't say no and they
being the people with obesity and I
don't believe that's true. And then,
or is it some specific item or
some specific group in this,
these foods that travel with western
populations and so the exists the ability
and today if you look up a dual
burden of obesity and malnutrition,
I have a Dropbox folder
I could share with you.
There's probably 50 studies all over
the world. You see the same observation,
incredibly poor populations,
malnourished. The children are stunted,
which they're protein deficient in their
calorie deficient and often the mothers
are, the ants are obesity. Obesity
tends to run in the females,
which suggests it has a female
sex hormone related effect.
Fact that I don't believe works in
the brain because we're dealing with
populations that could not have overeaten
if they could have overeaten why are
the kids starving?
That's sort of the question and this was
the first thing that I think we swapped
about back then,
and it's still,
if you can find populations
with obesity epidemics,
but without the modern food system,
without Snackwells and without
Lay's potato chips. Um,
and if you know that they're going through
a famine or you know that the kids at
least aren't getting a food,
how do you explain obesity and the mothers
without assuming that the mothers are
overheating? Let's pause
right there. Stefan,
is there a population of people that
are obese that are not eating a western
diet?
They're not eating sugary foods,
um, that are obese and that
are not eating sugary foods?
Probably not.
Because generally once you have an
industrialized food system that's going to
include sugar,
but there are populations that eat
a lot of sugar and are not obese.
And we should talk about some of
these actual, let's, let's about the,
go back to the, yeah, sure. Let's
talk about the Pima first. Um,
now Gary has told his story.
He's told his version of the Pima story.
Let me tell the story,
the version of the story that appears in
the scientific literature. Now, the Pima,
um,
originally they were agriculturalists.
They were eating traditionally a very
high carbohydrate diet based on unrefined
carbohydrates. Originally it
was corn, beans and squash.
Primarily they were hunter gatherers,
agriculture. They were primarily Gary.
Okay. They were primarily
eating agricultural foods.
They were also collecting some
wild foods. That's correct. Um,
they were fishing and
eating the skeet pods.
Primarily agricultural and
data are very clear on that, Gary. So, no,
no, no. Yes, they are. Look, we have data.
You can't say things like that to happen
because we're going to die. Well, let's,
let's, let's move on. You think they
mostly fish? That's incorrect. Okay.
According to the data,
I remember you saying that in your book.
Something to that effect. Read Book.
You've got my book. Anyway, let's,
let's go on. We don't, that's fine.
I'm going to move on here. Um,
now the Pima traditionally
were agriculturalists and Wa.
What happened basically is you had all
these farmers moving into their area,
settlers of European descent,
and they diverted the water from
their river, the Gila or healer river,
if you alone for now Hilo. And so they
were no longer able to grow their crops,
their agricultural crops that
they were primarily dependent on.
And therefore the government started
providing them with foods to eat.
And these were calorie dense refined
foods. They were like Gary said, uh,
flour,
lard and sugar.
And then they became very obese.
Now there was a population of Pima right
across the border from them in Mexico,
also very similar culturally and all that,
that maintain their traditional high
carbohydrate lifestyle and agricultural
lifestyle.
And there've been studies comparing
those two populations and the ones across
the border with their traditional
lifestyle or a lot leaner and healthier,
not surprisingly than the ones eating
lard, flour and sugar. Okay. But Gary,
uh, you seem to believe
that people can gain weight.
You kept referring to famines and things.
You seem to believe that people can gain
weight even if they are eating very few
calories. And you have referred to
this many times in your writing. Um,
and you know,
these are very casual observations
that you're making kind of these casual
correlations and storytelling.
But if you actually look
at the data on this,
what you see is that if you just measure
calorie intake in people who have
obesity,
it is 20 to 35% higher than people who
are lean after correcting for height,
physical activity level. Um,
and that I've got the references
we're getting, we're getting a
little bit into that means here,
but let me give you an exuberance number
seven, can I pause you guys right here?
These people,
they have essentially the same lineage.
One group lives in Mexico.
They,
they're not eating these sugary
foods and this western diet,
the ones that live in America are the
ones that live in America are becoming
obese. The ones that live in Mexico or
not. Is that correct? Correct. Yeah.
And so now if you have someone
with obesity, like I've said,
the most accurate measures that we have
suggest that they habitually consume and
expend more calories.
And now Gary's model says that that
is downstream of the fattening effect.
It's not causing the fattening effect.
It is a result of the fattening effect.
Whereas my model says that
that is actually required
for the fattening effects
to occur. It has upstream. So now
what happens? What happens here?
What happens if you reduce their
calorie intake by that same amount,
20 to 35%. It doesn't matter if you
do it by restricting carbs or fat.
These experiments have been done.
They lose weight when you restrict
their calorie intake down to that.
This is the argument what you're saying
that you keep consuming low amounts of
calories but high amounts of sugar does.
It doesn't make sense.
You can get obese that way.
Um, when you're saying it's
a calorie, yeah, correct.
And that's referenced number nine and 10.
Um,
to support what I just said and I want
to talk about another one that really can
we out on stuff. That's
what, what I, the reason
I was using the dual burden example is
because we have to explain how those
women reading all those
calories. Usually women, again,
it's just often it was in trough in
these studies were done by diabetes
researchers who were studying diabetes
in these populations and the men had high
levels of diabetes in the women
had to high levels of obesity. Um,
to give you an example where
that measurement was done
in Trinidad in the 1960s
and again, all I'm doing, this is the
role I played as I asked the question,
can you find populations that
don't have a lot of food? Okay.
You could say that the obese expend
a lot of energy and they ate a lot of
calories. The question is can they
get obese without a lot of food?
And so can we find populations like us?
Can you find a population
that gets obese without sugar?
Which was exactly the question to ask.
So in Trinidad,
in the 1960s as a malnutrition crisis,
the u s government sends a team of
researchers down to study this and the
researchers come back and say, yeah,
there's malnutrition, there's stunting,
there's deficiency diseases.
And two thirds of the adult women are
obese and this is a medical problem.
And the next year and MIT nutritionists
goes down to do exactly what Stephan s
four and to actually measure the diets
and obese women and lean women and to
study it. And this is the population,
whether it's, it's unlike,
I mean this is a very poor Trinidad
and population and reports that they,
I think it was 1800 calories a day with
the obese woman reading was actually a
little less than what the lean people
seem to be eating and that it was lower
than what the Food and
Agriculture Organization
considered for a healthy diet.
So again,
what my role in this is to point out
when you have populations like that,
I don't see how the overeating hypothesis
tells me the brain is in control of
how much they eat tells me anything
about why the women were obese,
especially when their kids are starving.
This is the paradox of the stool burden.
An obese mother with a starving child,
if there'll be some other,
has to eat superfluids
calories to get fat.
Why hasn't she given those calories to
our kids? Because she doesn't need him.
She clearly doesn't need them. She's
got fuel, so what's going on there?
If you posit a hypothesis as I did,
which says that the obesity is triggered
by the macronutrient content of the
Diet, then you can explain. I mean
there are plenty of animal models.
A famous quote I use in my
books from John my year,
it was like the fame leading Harvard
nutritionists who studied an ob strain of
animals in the 50s he said, my animals
will get fat. Even when half starved,
they will make fat out of their food.
Even when half starved is are generally
animals with mutations in the Leptin.
It doesn't, whatever
gene, whatever gene it is.
It's kind of the question is if Mike,
I can make fat out of my food at levels of
caloric levels at for instance,
a lean person can't,
then I'm going to get fat eating the
same amount and that fat
accumulation is going to be,
you know means I'm taking in
more calories and I expand.
But the point is I'm for some
metabolic hormonal reason,
I'm taking the fuel I eat and turning
it into fat and storing it in the fat
tissue. What does your responses? Yeah,
so my response is that if
you want the best answers,
you have to use the best methods to
answer it, to answer the questions. Okay.
Do you want a question answered properly?
You have to use accurate methods to
answer that question. Now, as you know,
Gary, it's very difficult to measure
food intake and free living individuals.
Particularly you're traveling to a
country you've never been to before.
It's very difficult to
get accurate measures.
So just because some guy went to
Trinidad and claim woman actual, okay,
fine.
Just because some woman went to Trinidad
and claimed that people were eating
1800 calories and becoming obese does
not mean that that's what actually
happened. Now, let me, no, no,
no, no. Gary, I'm responding now.
We have studies where researchers used
accurate measures to measure calorie
intake in people who had obesity.
Many of these people were saying,
we're only eating 1200 calories a day.
When they actually measured
their calorie intake.
What they found was that
they were consistently eating
more calories than lean
people.
So this,
this phenomenon that Gary describes is
something that is only observed when
inferior methods are
used to measure calories.
The reason I'm using these populations,
like I said,
I'm just giving you an observation.
Ob smaller with a starving child,
the dual burden of malnutrition,
obesity. This isn't one observation,
it's not one nutritionist.
The existence of the starving children
strongly suggests that there's not a lot
of food available and we have to
explain obesity in the model. You know,
I would like you to respond. Okay,
fine. I will respond to that. Now look,
I haven't looked at these
studies in particular.
I brought them up eight years ago.
We got in a fight about it [inaudible]
years ago. It ruined our, you know,
it's like are we used to
be by. So now look, um,
there are many reasons why a child
could be malnourished in a nonindustrial
situation.
And this is,
I do a lot of work related to this and
what you see in nonindustrial situations,
you see a lot of infectious disease.
You see a lot of um,
malnutrition.
So people not getting enough essential
minerals and vitamins not getting enough
protein.
And you see a lot of children who are
just barely hanging on because of this
collection of really bad stuff that's
happening in their lives. And so sites,
things. Yeah, yeah. Parasites, malaria.
I Dunno if there's malaria and Trinidad
or not, but I mean all the diarrhea,
pneumonia, these are the
things that we all had before.
We had modern medicine
and great sanitation.
And then the country
like the United States,
30% of kids didn't even
make it past childhood.
And so there's a lot of things
that could have caused that. Gary.
It's not necessarily because,
you know,
it's not necessarily the reason
that you attribute it to now.
I'm not attributing it to a reason. I'm
just asking. Okay, well great. Well, I,
I don't have the explanation,
but I'm throwing out possibilities that
are alternative to the one that you're
implying is quite
possible. Okay. So now, um,
I, so again, when you use accurate
measures of calorie intake,
you find that these people with magical
metabolisms who have obesity and don't
eat very much seem to not exist
anymore. Um, and furthermore, I want to,
I want to get to us to another type
of study that's really going to
differentiate between this metabolic
effect driven by insulin and the effect of
calories.
So we have a lot of studies that compared
diets in which calories were the same
but carbohydrate and fat intake deferred.
And the ones that I really want to focus
on right now that I think are key here
are this studies where they
increased calorie intake.
So they fed people, they f one
study in particular. And um,
let's see, I'm going to
give you a number here. Um,
let me see if I can give you
a number here. Sorry. Why
don't you look at that. Um,
can we,
uh,
bring up another issue because what we're
talking about ultimately is why people
get fat. Okay. I don't, I
don't want to divert here. I'm
in the middle of something.
So,
um,
now if we want to understand
why people get fat,
we can look at studies that overfed
people on fat or carbohydrate exclusively.
So this one study, um, the first
one that I want to talk about first,
they figured out people's
baseline calorie intake,
figure out how many calories
they need to just to maintain.
And then they increase that by 50% by
exclusively giving them fat or exclusively
giving them carbohydrate. Okay,
study was, this is Horton. Okay.
Um, give me a yes, a
number 16, number 16. So,
um,
now if Gary's hypothesis is correct,
these people should have gained body fat
on the carbohydrate overfeeding but not
the fat overfeeding because
that increases your insulin,
it has these effects on your
fat cells, et Cetera. Okay.
Now these were very rigorous studies.
I want to emphasize that they monitor the,
the actual Khoury's that got correct.
Yes, they were. They were good.
They had a baseline. They use prisoners
and they per month state prison. No,
that's incorrect. This is a different
study. So they, they had a baseline.
And did they require them to maintain
the same dye and then add additional fat
or additional carbohydrates?
Yes. So same guy, same food,
and then they just bump it up with
fat, with carbohydrate, Horton.
It wasn't Sims, it was anything stems.
Well which talking the monkey, that was
which study did you do that was
not prisoners? What was the, uh,
he didn't have a metabolic,
you know what?
Let me just finish describing
the study and we can, Gary,
that's an irrelevant detail.
Okay.
What's relevant is that you just implied
that I don't know what I'm talking
about, Harry. You know what? I don't
actually know. Maybe it was in prison.
Thank you. All right.
You're welcome. Now. Um,
but it was not the Sims overfeeding
study that was done in prison.
That's what I know. Okay. Okay. So what's
the reference? Yeah, it's on my website.
You can go to my website,
Stephan,
dna.com and it's referenced number
16 and they're both there. Okay.
So this was what's called a metabolic
ward study where these people were in a
research facility where the researchers
could monitor and control every morsel
of food. So there was no
cheating, no inaccuracy.
And they were measuring changes in body
fatness using a gold standard method
called underwater weighing.
Okay.
And so what they found was that at the
end of a two week period of over feeding
the carb and the fat groups gained
the exact same amount of body fat,
exact same amount of body fat.
There was another second study that did
the same thing and found the same result.
Independent lab group,
very similar experiment.
Three week long instead of two weeks,
they found the exact same thing,
same amount of fat gain,
different insulin responses,
different amounts of carbohydrate in
that exact same amount of fat gain.
So this demonstrates that insulin is not,
and carbs are not what controls
what gets fat into fat tissue.
Calorie intake is what controls that.
So let me explain it again.
Remember I talked about the paradigm you
work in determines the question you ask.
And this experiment is a classic example
because they assume that people get fat
by overfeeding.
So then they say if we overfeed them,
we've just doing what happens naturally.
Everything about the experiment is based
on the assumption that they're supposed
to be testing, which is Ken. People
get fat by overfeed it. And so the,
from the Berry conception
of the experiment they've
built in the paradigm that
we want to test the hypothesis,
I'm on top of it.
If it's a typical sims experiment,
I actually wasn't familiar with this one.
Oh it was a,
it wasn't sims was a James.
Oh Jc Peter.
James Hill was funded for the,
from about 1998 to about 2008 by proctor
and gamble cause he was in a less Stra
shill. I hate to say that
Jim, I apologize, but I
think it's a fair assessment.
And then when he stopped being
funded by proctor and gamble,
he was funded by the sugar industry.
He's and JC Peters was the
head of the Procter and gamble,
Leicester, Leicester, which is now
something that no one eats. Yeah,
Lester was a fat substituted.
It problem was you'd got like run out
shit like that but the whole idea of a
Lustra was to replace fat in the Diet.
So every study hoe and
Peters did implicated dietary
fat as a cause of obesity.
I don't think we could ever use,
I hate to say it, I'm typically I,
I don't think funding influences
results but I wouldn't use it.
James Hill study to make that point that
because you think it's a biased
study that was in everything.
Everything Helen Peters did and one knows.
I mean I talked about
this in good calories,
bad calories when they
reported their results.
Actually I did a foyer on James Hill
cause he works for the University of
Colorado.
You could actually get,
I got all his documents back and
forth between him and the Lester.
I'd be happy to share them with
you if you'd like there. Rebel at,
I mean him and proctor and gamble but
he basically held Procter and gamble for
ransom.
He would get a $500,000 unrestricted gift
and then he would do a study and then
he would ask and it would conclude
that fat is bad and carbs are good and
therefore a Lester as a viable product.
Then he would ask for proctor and gamble
for more money before he then published
study.
So it's a particularly egregious
example of someone who's,
I suspect it was just a belief system.
He believed dietary fat,
what's bad fat causes obesity.
Uh,
Lester is a good thing because you eat
that instead of fat and you don't absorb
it. And then every study
he did confirm that. Um,
the point that we keep getting away from
that I haven't had an opportunity to,
um,
and Stephanie knows this as well as I do.
If you're gaining say four pounds a year
of fat or let's say between 20 and 40,
you've put on 40 extra pounds. So
now you're obese, you're nice, lean,
healthy young guy in 20, like many of
us were. And by the time you're 40,
you've got 40 pounds of excess fat.
That's the equivalent of putting in about
a 10 calories is had storing about 10
calories a day into your fat tissue
that you don't burn a metabolized.
So you eat,
say 2,700 calories a day,
half carbs, you know,
35% fat, 15% protein,
and 10 calories that they get
trapped in your fat tissue,
less than a bytes worth the food
less than a sips worth of beer.
So the question we're actually
trying to ask is our answer,
and this is again just my approach as a
curious journalists too with a science
background. This, how do we
explain those 10 calories?
Because when we talk about those
obese women with starving children,
all those obese women were doing was
storing 10 or 20 calories a day depending
on how quickly they became obese.
And those populations that tends
to happen quickly in their 20s. Um,
so we're asking this question,
how do we,
if you've got a situation where we have
to end up with 10 calories stuck in the
fat cells every day, that's
2030, 40 billion fat cells.
So it's divided up very small.
And is the brain somehow
regulating that or again,
is her a dysregulation in the
body involving pick your hormones,
pick your enzymes when the one,
um,
that somehow traps fat in the fat cells
or prevents the fat from being used for
fuel when it's released
from the fat cells.
And so if you think about it that way,
like you let yourself go to seeds today,
Joe Rogan decides I'm done.
I'm going to do nothing but drink beer.
And you might start drinking five beers
a day and over the course of 10 years
you get 20 pounds.
And it's all here.
That 20 pounds over the course of 10
years is still only about 20 calories.
You might've added 800 calories of beer
to your diet and stored 20 calories as
fat. How does that happen
and why does it go here
and not elsewhere?
And as Stephen said,
this is insulin dependent
fat tissue. Um, so those are,
that's one we're talking
about this like this question,
could somebody get fat during a famine
or can they stay fat during a fam?
And all they have to do is hold
on to 10 calories a day extra.
If they're only eating 1,210
gets stuck in their fat cells,
1,190 is excrete it or are expended.
It's not that hard to imagine. And
there's nothing in the laws of physics.
It says it.
So what could be dysregulated about their
fat cells even during a relative fam
and not a complete fem and but a relative
fem. And that might be, and again,
an animal experiments of which
there are probably hundreds by now,
different animal models.
You can disassociate obesity from hype,
from eating too much in the animals.
Can I pause you for a second? Yeah.
So essentially you're saying that
even if someone is taking in,
uh, a good amount of cowers at the
s the s a smart amount of calories,
2000 calories a day,
if you're taking in these
calories in the form of sugar,
your body is going to take a
certain percentage of them,
even if you're getting enough
food and stored as fat.
Whereas if you were taking in just protein
and vegetables and things along those
lines,
your body would not do that well.
So this is a gets to the
mechanism question and the
evidence question but you're
saying that right? So you're saying that
if two people were on the same diet,
one of them's on 2000 calories of chicken
and fish and vegetables and the other
one is on 2000 calories of milkshakes
and you know sugary drinks and pasta and
bullshit that that person is going to
gain a certain amount of calories and just
put them to fat. Right.
Regardless that yeah,
that [inaudible]
this being a science, that hypothesis
can be tested and Stephan, thanks.
It's been tested 80
times. Stephanie, it's,
they've done a bad job of testing it and
we will both tend to reject the studies
that we don't like when we define don't
light by whether or not they got the
answer.
We think
your perspective is that
this is not the case.
Your perspective is that like as you
were saying in this study with a closely
monitored these people's diets and
the added additional fat and had an
additional carbohydrates that they both
gained the same additional amount of
what it's right. I mean if cases
isn't shot, this is correct.
You have to see different
levels of fat gain.
I mean a short term study that did was
how short term was it a two in three
weeks. That's very short.
Yeah, it is very short term.
But Still Gary says that insulin is the
thing that gets fat in fat cells and
that, I mean you would see
some kind of difference.
It insulin made any difference but you
should've seen some kind of effect, right?
Some kind of difference in fact game.
Um,
I don't want to start taking out charts,
but this gets into insulin dynamics
that was worked out so over, uh,
um,
I promised I wasn't going to say oil boy.
Why on the show, but it's my
thanks to my Brooklyn born mother.
It's my programmed in.
Um,
and a the same is true. A lot of these
overfeeding experiments do the same thing.
So when they talk about over feeding,
they, they, they literally over feed.
So they kind of do a reasonable way of
figuring out which reading is Stephen.
They measured,
uh,
they calculated how much energy they
needed to stay in energy and balance.
And again,
right there,
that's a problem because one of the
hypotheses says that the energy balance is
dependent on the macronutrient
content of the food.
So you're going to get a different
different level depending on what the
macronutrient content is
and then different level of,
of what what's necessary
for energy balance.
So the classic example is a study
that's my not for profit funded,
that's been very controversial where they
got their subjects,
this is David Ludwig and get rambling.
And there their colleagues at that,
that Harvard and Boston Children's
Hospital and they did this study in
Framingham and they,
they basically got, uh,
subjects to lose 10 or 12% of their body
weight and then they randomized them to
three different diets have three
different macronutrient composition.
Then they basically calculated their
energy expenditure on the three different
diets,
which is kind of exactly what we're
talking about because if you want to be an
energy balance, who know, you feed
people exactly what they're expanding.
And in that study,
which was published a year ago,
and they saw different levels of
energy expenditure depending on the
carbohydrate content of the Diet.
So the higher level of carbohydrates,
this is trying to keep them in energy
balance. The, the higher the carbohydrate,
the lower the energy expenditure,
the lower the carbohydrate,
the higher the energy expenditure.
So again,
it's just whether or not they
did the study, right? Who knows.
Science is a compilation of a lot of
studies and we're trying to, you know,
address exactly this point,
but
merely building that into the experiment,
we know what their energy
expenditure should be.
And then the point is when
you increase in part, again,
part of the trick of doing
science, it's to say, look,
we have competing hypotheses,
uh, multiple hypotheses.
And it's vitally important that you always
keep the multiple hypotheses in mind
when you're interpreting the study.
So one hypothesis says it's how much
they eat and another hypothesis says it's
what they eat and that what they eat is,
is moderated primarily through insulin.
And when you do these experiments
at the experiment that, that uh,
Steve, so Steven is
talking about Stephan, um,
I'm completely confused.
Uh, if you overfeed them,
you start out with a 50% carb diet.
Now you overfeed them.
If there's a threshold effect on insulin,
which turns out there is,
then you're just moving them. And when
you're looking at insulin dynamics,
when insulin is below a very low point,
the fat cells will mobilize
fat and the lean tissue,
we'll burn it for fuel. And above
that point you get pretty much flat.
So if you start people who are eating
1500 calories from carbs and you add them,
bump them up to 2,500 calories from carbs
are still in the plateau side of the
incident, you wouldn't necessarily
expect to see any difference.
The only way you expect
to see a difference.
And that's why it helps
to really interrogate both
hypotheses so that you know
when you're doing the experiment,
whether or not you're actually
testing something, you one hypothesis,
you want to set up the experiments with
a hypothesis predicts the two hypotheses.
Predict something entirely different.
This experiment,
arguably the two hypotheses
predict the same thing.
You'll get fat gain because
insulin is elevated regardless,
and when insulin is elevated,
you're going to get fat gain.
The question comes back to this again,
always fight on to keep this in mind.
We want to what could possibly cause at
10 or 20 calorie excess that causes fat
storage. I have a friend that was
for 400 pounds when he was 18.
It was a tall kid, about six
foot five. Um, he was, uh,
say 200 pounds over weight,
200 pounds overweight is roughly a hundred
excess calories over 18 years stored
in your fat cells. That's, you know,
even if you assume that you have to
consume 300 calories to have 100 excess
stored in your fat
cells, that's, you know,
one to Coca Cola is a day that he was
drinking or one half a quarter pounder or
a day that he was eating.
And that is lean friends warrant.
And the question would be, why can't
you just stop doing that? And again,
Stephan would say,
cause there's brain won't let him and
I would say because his insulin is
elevated, it doesn't matter
whether he stops it or not,
he's got into your Tressie
underlying mechanism. Okay. Um,
all right, so now again,
it's easy to tell stories.
It's not easy to tell stories that are
supported by scientific evidence. Now,
um,
I want to bring people's attention
to reference number 11 on my site.
There have been 29 studies now that
have measured differences in energy
expenditure, metabolic for Kevin
Hall study met analysis, correct.
There've been 29 studies to date that
I've measured calorie expenditure,
metabolic rate on diets differing
in carbohydrate and fat content.
And when you put all
those studies together,
when you are at least the first 28
together and you look at what the overall
literature says,
it makes almost no difference to
metabolic rate whether people are eating
carbohydrate or fat.
And in fact this very small difference
that it does make actually favors high
carbohydrate diets.
So you get a slightly higher metabolic
rate when the Diet is predominantly
carbohydrate.
Now this study that Gary's side is
the one study out of these 29 that has
reported a larger effect than any others
of carbohydrate restriction on energy
expenditure.
So this study reported and affect
bigger than any of these other 28 and
different. Sweet, thank you.
Um, and, and interestingly,
if you actually look at the data and
these data have been Rhea analyzed by a
researcher named Kevin Hall.
And if you look at the data,
you find that some of the participants,
some of the data that represent some
of these participants are literally
physically impossible. They break
the first law of thermodynamics.
This is the conservation of energy.
Gary knows about this.
He has a physics background and
they literally don't add up.
And when you start subtracting the,
the clearly erroneous data
from the pool of subjects,
this big effect size starts to shrink
and shrink and shrink and shrink until
after you've gotten rid of all of it.
This study does no longer,
no longer reports a higher
energy expenditure on a
very low carbohydrate diet
and it's consistent with the
previous 28 studies that were done.
So that's my perspective on that.
But I want to go back to this [inaudible]
you taught her a long time and I'm
going to talk for as long as I want.
Now I want to,
I want to talk about human energy
metabolism in this idea of the 10 extra
calories a day. Gary, I,
I really continue to get the feeling that
you do not understand human energetics,
um, because that's not
how it works. But no,
just saying 10 calories
stored in the fat tissue,
10 calories and say anything about how
much you have to eat. I'm not done. Okay.
No, but you're in me. Sorry.
You got to stop doing that dude.
Keep acting like you think I'm an idiot.
All right. Are you done now? Are you done?
Can we be clear that we're
talking about you done now?
Can I just finish this until I'm dying?
Without Gary,
you had time to respond.
You can respond,
write down notes on what you want
to respond to and after he's done,
you can tell him,
but we're going to get into a long
course on something that's not the point.
Fine. Thank you. Okay,
now what you see,
there's basically two things you need
to pay attention to here in terms of
energetics.
One is the imbalance between
intake and expenditure,
and that is very small,
so it only takes a little bit of extra
calories to cause somebody to start
gaining fat. However, as they
gain fat, their bodies get bigger.
They're gaining fat and lean mass.
People with obesity have more fat and
more lean mass and their calorie needs go
up and up and up and up.
The larger their bodies get.
And so even though the imbalance between
energy and taking expenditure is small,
their calorie needs end up being quite
a bit higher. So I pause for a second.
Yeah. So you're saying that
someone just gaining calories,
eating additional calories, their body
gains lean mass as well? That's correct.
How does the brain regulate that? I didn't
say it regulated by the dog. Hold on.
That's so fascinating.
How does the play muscle muscle,
they're gaining muscle to some
of his muscles. Some of it's
because it's because they're carrying
around this extra weight and so the extra
calories and then on top of that carrying
around the extra weight forces your
body to grow larger. Presumably I'm, I'm
actually not sure what the mechanism is,
but it doesn't have anything
to do with the brain.
I don't know what causes it. That's
what I'm saying, Gary. Okay. Now, um,
so,
but the point is by the
time the person has obesity,
they are consuming 20 to 35% more calories
than they were when they were lean.
So that's not just a
one or two cokes a day.
That is allowing them to remain obese.
They are consuming 20
to 35% more calories.
That is with the most
accurate studies are saying.
And so it's not just 10 extra calories
or maybe just one or two cokes.
We're talking about a substantial
amount of extra calories.
And isn't this a generalization
because we don't know what I mean?
What's the ratio of how much fat people
get, how much weight people are gaining.
Everybody gains a
different amount of weight.
And you're saying they're eating 20 to
30% more cowers like who is like how many
people, how much are they
gaining? Or people get fat,
they get 20 pounds overweight.
People get fat,
they get a hundred pounds overweight.
They'd be a that's right. Yeah.
And that's why I give a range because
what you see is that people who are
overweight, so they're in the overweight
range, you just have some extra fat.
They eat about 10% extra calories.
People who have a little bit of
obesity eat about 20% extra calories.
People who have, who are very,
have very, very great obesity,
eat more like 35%. So it tracks
with the amount, I'm sorry,
is it possible what he was saying that
if you do consume 10 extra calories over
long periods of time, that will
accumulate extra calories cumulate
like pen diamonds going into this.
So how much do you have to DePaul?
It is correct.
It is correct that if every day you eat
10 calories more than what you need,
then yes. Or your body or
your body stores. Yeah.
I will say that if your
body is storing 10%, 10,
10 extra calories over
top of what you need,
but the thing is that as you get bigger,
what you need goes up and
up and up because you're
carrying around more correct.
And so it's 10% and Tenex or
cow it, sorry, not percent.
It's 10 extra calories on
top of the elevated amount
that you're already eating.
So you end up with these big differences
in calories tick. So that's how,
that's how it really works.
But I want to talk about, um,
some interesting observations
because Gary, you like to
talk about, um, you know,
what's going on in different dietary
trends and different cultures.
And I find that pretty interesting too.
I want to talk about the fact that sugar
intake in the United States has been
declining for the last 20 years.
So it peaked in 1999 and it is currently,
depending on which source
of evidence you believe,
15 to 23% lower than it was in 1999.
This has been corroborated by a number
of different sources of evidence.
This is number 17 on my blog.
And of course we know that
obesity has increased.
Diabetes has increased substantially over
the last 20 years in the percentage of
the population are actually
numbers percentage. Yeah. And uh,
and UK sugar intake has been declining
for 50 years. I don't believe that.
Okay, well, you can argue with the data.
They're a number 17 and my
blog there are about 22% lower.
And this is what we see across
a number of different, uh,
industrialized countries.
You see a stagnation or decline and
sugar intake in recent decades as obesity
rates are continuing to increase.
And of course that 50 year period that
covers the decline in the UK covers the
entire UK obesity and diabetes epidemics.
Um,
but there's another one I want to talk
about that and I respond to that. Yeah,
we should probably look sponsor Stephan,
actually I'll let you respond for me
because we had this debate with the Keto
Foundation. So you know my
art counterargument, you
want to give it? Yeah, sure.
Absolutely. I mean are you sure
you want to let me give it though,
am I correct that? Okay. All right.
So your counter argument is that
the amount of that we consumed
20 years ago or even maybe 50 years ago,
maybe continuing to fatten us today and
it's about the sugar that we used to eat
20 or 50 years ago and not necessarily
about the sugar we eat today.
Well it's not exactly right. Okay. I get,
the argument I made was because he
brought this up when we've had to do a
written debate on the
Keto Foundation website.
And it's interesting if you think
about use tobaccos and example.
So tobacco smoking per capita smoking in
America peaked in 1965 right up to the
surgeon general's report and it took 30
years before lung cancer rates turned
over.
Okay.
And I think we both agree that cigarettes
are a major cause of lung cancer
smoking. So what you basically
have is a system in which,
if there are any,
there's the assumption that Stephanie is
making when he quotes this kind of data,
is that the relationship between
sugar and obesity is linear.
So it's sugar goes up, obesity and
diabetes goes up, and if sugar turns over,
they don't. So here's the thought
experiment I used in Keto, which has
1965 or smoke in per capita,
about 20 cigarettes a day.
As it starts to come down,
imagine we only cut that to 17
cigarettes or 16 cigarettes,
a 20% reduction in smoking.
Would you expect to see a reduction
in the lung cancer rates? Again,
this is the point I made about what
you would expect to see rather than new
things. Simplistic Metaphor. So the
question is, would you like Joe,
we go from 20 to 16. Do you expect to
see the lung cancer rates turnover?
No. No. And in sugar we went
from drop a know you might,
the derivative might drop.
You might expect it to slow a tiny bit.
Still use,
there was a bunch of weird comparison
because one of them was poisoned.
The other one's food, right? Well,
but then this case, the food,
the question is how toxic is the food?
So in sugar, we have a variety in sugar.
What happened is the equivalent of going
from 20 cigarettes to 16 beginning in
1999 and Stephen is saying,
I would expect to see an immediate
change in obese. And in fact,
if you actually look at the rates,
the,
the rate of increase in the prevalence
appeared to plateau around six or seven
years later. Uh, who knows
whether that's relevant,
but to get a small decrease
in sugar 20 [inaudible],
even if it's 20%,
that's 20 to 16 cigarettes.
And I'm saying the other factor that I
talk about my book and stuff in those,
this is very clearly have
maternal transmission of the
propensity to obesity and
diabetes.
So there's a generational effect.
This and this is studies
that were done in the same,
on the same pm the same native American
tribe where each generation if gets more
and more,
uh,
susceptible to whatever it is in the
Diet that's triggering and obesity and
diabetes. So that's been happening in
the United States and around the world.
You've got a generational effect
that could last far longer,
might even keep going indefinitely
even if their sugar levels drop.
So you have the sugar quick kicking
off the obesity epidemic and yet it's
Stephan's about to say this
is a story and it is a story,
but it's clearly the case that mothers
who are obese during pregnancy or
diabetic or gestationally diabetic,
they become diabetic during pregnancy
or they have metabolic syndrome,
they're just a insulin resistant or
they gain a lot of weight in pregnancy,
will give birth to children who are at
higher risk of becoming an obese and
diabetic when they get older.
And a younger age was in those children
will pass it on. So again, we have,
you know,
I would be nice,
I would love it if sugar consumption
came down and with it. Um,
obesity and diabetes plummeted,
but it's not a in any way
reputation of this hypothesis,
which I just want to state what it is
because people get confused about it and
we never got to it.
The sugar hypothesis is a little different
than what we've been talking about
and it's pretty simple.
We have obesity and diabetes
epidemics worldwide as we talked to.
It doesn't matter the
genetics of the population.
You add something about a western
diet to those populations,
western Diet and lifestyle,
you get these explosions.
Fifth epidemics of obesity and diabetes.
And what I'm hypothesizing in
this book is that sugar is a,
something that has to be added. Maybe
it's sugary beverages for all I know.
Maybe or it could be, you know,
a more complex hypothesis,
a singer possible.
One is you add sugar to any
population to dye it in sufficient,
whether it's southeast Asians living on
Rice or the annual it living on reindeer
and whatever,
or the native Americans to
the great plains or you know,
Caucasians living in the
upper east side of Manhattan,
add enough sugar and eventually through
the metabolic effects of the sugar and
the generational effects,
you will get explosions of obesity
and diabetes and metabolic.
You want to respond to that? Sure.
I mean, Gary, you called it man.
It's always possible to tell a
story to salvage your hypothesis,
but that doesn't necessarily
make the story correct. I mean,
I can come up with a story that cosmic
rays cause obesity by hitting my fat
cells and making them fat.
You can't disprove that.
Nobody here can disprove that,
but there's no evidence of an experiment
to protect you from, okay. We don't have,
we don't have the data right
now. You don't have data
supporting your hypothesis.
No, we do. You're just dismissed.
Can I get back to the camera?
Let's let them respond them on
Kevin Hall leader. Yeah. So, um,
what do you think about what he's saying
about sugar and increased rates of
diabetes and that this is the
cross? Yeah, I mean, so let me,
it this way.
We don't have any evidence
supporting what he just said.
So that is a story that is
not supported by evidence.
Now does it, does that mean
that is definitely incorrect.
No, I cannot say that.
That's definitely incorrect.
Same Way.
I can't say it's definitely incorrect
that cosmic rays cause obesity.
But you know, I'm going
to, I'm going to use it,
Christopher Hitchens quote here that which
is asserted without evidence does not
require evidence to refute.
And that's the way I feel about this
particular story. Um, but you know,
there are cultures that consume large
amounts of sugar and do not develop
obesity. We've talked about,
and we're going to talk
about it again right now. Um,
so this is referenced number 21.
I'm on my blog. I'm going to talk
about three different cultures,
one of which we have not talked
about, Gary. The first one is the uh,
the Hadza hunter gatherers of Tanzania.
This is a really interesting
nonindustrial culture.
They as part of their hunter
gatherer diet, eat a lot of honey.
Honey is a very common food among hunter
gatherers living similarly to how our
ancestors used to live. And if you
measure there year round honey and take,
it's about 15% of their calories. So
this is a major calorie source for them.
That's about as much sugar
as the average American eats.
And they eat fruit sugar on top of this.
They eat a lot of fruit on top of that.
And so they're eating
quite a bit of sugar.
And the Hadza men have about 12%
body fat women have about 18.
So they correspond pretty
closely to our western ideals.
What isn't that high for hunter
gatherers? No, not really. I mean,
that's higher than me. Uh, hang
around. Bless me. Ask you this.
How have you had your body
fatness measured? What amount?
A measured a bunch of ways.
Electricity.
I've added this machine where
you hold onto these things.
Just stand on this platform
and the physician's office of,
okay, so I'm with calipers the most. Okay.
So all the methods that you measure
that you mentioned are not gold standard
methods.
So the gold standard methods
are underwater weighing
and the underwater weighing
these people on this island.
Uh, actually I'm not sure.
I'm not sure how to bring that equipment
to this island. Correct. But okay, look,
um, I can tell you that you can look
up photos. I don't remember how they,
how they measured their body fat, but you
can look, I am 12% as measured by Dexa.
So I'll just tell you that so you can
get a sense of what 12% is by Dexa.
Um, which is a gold standard method. Um,
so you can look at photos of these people.
They're very fit. They're lean,
they're not like ripped, you know,
they're not Arnold Schwartz and
Egger and peak form, but they are,
I understand it,
but it seems to correlate with a higher
consumption of sugar that they seem to
have a higher percentage of body fat
than the average hunter gatherer.
Now you look at a lot of the
average a hundred gatherers,
like a friend of mine does a lot
of work with the pygmies and uh,
the Congo and they've very lean.
Okay, so you see him sees packs.
That's the second culture. I was going to
cite that Ethan kind of honey, do they?
Yeah. If they're the same ones and
little booty pygmies of the Congo,
um,
they eat up to 80% of their calories can
come from honey during the rainy season.
So they also eat a lot of honey and our
lean not just leave the year. Correct.
Yeah, it's for them.
It's part of the year.
The Hadza that you did more consistently
and the Hadza have low levels of body
fat. Their cardiovascular
risk markers are excellent.
They don't have diabetes.
Same.
But this is absolutely not like a
controlled study in the consumption. Not,
I absolutely agree with you.
And that's exactly the point I'm trying
to make is that when you have a culture
that is eating a lot of sugar,
but everything else is in place,
they're doing everything else right.
The sugar's not enough to make them fat.
It's not single handedly enough.
I'm not saying it doesn't contribute.
I think sugar does contribute.
I just to be very clear,
I think sugar does contribute to obesity
and diabetes and cardiovascular disease,
but it's not single handedly
responsible as Gary has argued.
So the third culture
is pretty interesting.
The Kuna of Panama and the reason
they're interesting is that they actually
aren't eating honey.
They're actually eating white sugar.
So there a culture that they live
primarily a nonindustrial lifestyle.
They're farmers and
hunter gatherers and um,
they,
but they do a little bit of trade and
one of the things they trade for us sugar
and they eat sugar
sweetened foods as well.
So like donuts and pastries and
they drink soda and Koolaid. What,
what is their lifestyle in terms of like
what do they have a natural lifestyle.
They are a hunter gatherers and
subsistence farmers. So they're, you know,
living a physically active,
natural lifestyle
problem and comparison with
any westernized civilization
that you burn off.
Sold many more cow.
100% agree with you.
And I think that is exactly the point.
I'm trying to make is that it's
more complicated than just sugar
is more complicated than
that and just sugar,
but with a normal lifestyle it may not be.
This is I the consumption,
the thing about burning of
the calories is also the, the,
the glucose demands a glycogen
demands on the muscle. You're, you're,
you're not just existing like the Wa,
one of the problems with Western lifestyle
is that many people are just existing.
They're sitting in a chair,
they're walking to a desk,
they're sitting in their car,
they're not doing anything to burn any
of this shit off. So even if you have,
like if you get a baseline of a minimal
amount of calories that you require for
the day, I think what Gary's
getting at is that if you,
if you have this lifestyle,
the lifestyle that many of us have,
and then with that lifestyle consume
sugar that you're going to get fat.
I don't think you can compare that
to athletes. And in that respect,
to a hunter gatherers because you're
requiring, it is a much more
significant load on your body.
Like when I do this sober October
fitness challenge with my friends during
October and we,
I was working out four hours a day and
I was fucking eating everything that
moved. I was drinking soda. I never
drink soda. I was eating cookies.
I didn't gain any weight other than
muscle. I didn't get any fat at all. Yeah.
And I was eating a terrible fucking die,
but I was going crazy.
When you're trying to stay alive and
you're running around plowing and growing
foods and hunting and
gathering and fishing,
you're burning off insane amounts of
calories. Just the hiking that's required,
the amount of exercise it's required.
It's off the charts in comparison
to standard western life.
We are on the same wavelength here.
I mean,
I completely agree with you that it is
more complicated than just sugar. And,
but if you read what Gary is written,
and please correct me if I'm wrong here,
Gary argues that sugar is the primary
cause of obesity and that physical
activity does not matter. Calorie
intake. Does it not matter?
Do you think the physical activity doesn't
matter? Uh, I think it's a, uh, uh,
no,
I don't think it makes a hell of a lot
of difference for fat when we're talking
about the cause of obesity.
I don't believe obese people get
obese because they're suddenly,
well let me put it this way.
So you take someone who's an elite
athlete and they start consuming a lot of
sugar, but they, they ramp up
their exercise accordingly.
Like say if someone does what
I did during the sober October,
they're working out three,
four hours a day every day.
You don't think that they have higher
sugar demands that their body would just
burn it.
I know, absolutely. I think that if
there's a real benefit to exercise,
it's burning off the carbohydrates you
consume then and you need less insulin to
do it. Can I respond to the Kona?
Get back to them for a second. Okay.
I mean one of the issues I have with
Stephen as he writes off my stories,
his stories,
which they are all science
began to stories on hypotheses.
And then what you'd do is go look for
the evidence and then he quotes studies
and refers to what has happened.
And this is somehow by
calling it evidence that may,
and then we had this discussion a year
and a half ago and you didn't disagree
with me at the time and
it had no influence.
So I'm just going to read from
the email I wrote to second.
It's creating emails. It's gotten to that
point in the conversation at deed it.
Well, because it's, I'm not only going
to read from the email if I have time,
I'm going to read from
your book read the Kuna.
The study you cited is interesting.
Okay.
So this was a study that profess to
measure sugar intake of this population on
an island and the Gandhi and compare it
to the population in Vera where they,
uh,
they had emigrated and I say,
but there added sugar and take an alta
according to figure one is 25 teaspoons
per week, plus the equivalent of
24 ounces of Sodas at 78 grams.
If it's coke 32 ounces of Koolaid,
that's 96 grams,
said I'm leaving out the cup of a sugar
cane because I don't know what that has
meant or how they assess it one way or
the other. It's not processed sugar.
So it's roughly 274 grams of sugar
per week or about 32 pounds per year.
Now,
that alone is very low intake and we
don't know how it changed over the years.
We have no idea if it's increasing
recently or been low for years.
So you just used the coon.
That's an example of a population
that eats a lot of sugar and stated at
dogmatically, but that a lot of sugars,
32 pounds a year. And then I said, wait,
hold on. I thought
that's what I heard. Uh,
if we believe the study,
the Coonan Vera Cruz are consuming
roughly the same amount, but I'm not sure.
I believe the study when it comes
to the Vera Cruz population,
do you really think these urbanized
coon are consuming only three,
eight ounce sodas per week?
So the implication was as population of
Caribbean islanders immigrates to Vera
Cruz,
they move into the city and they consume
more sugar back where they used to live
because they trade for it. Then
when they get into the city, um,
so five glasses of Koolaid, no
candy, no ice cream, nothing.
I'd like to know more about the urban
CUNA before I accept such an analysis is
valid on top of this.
As they say,
the analysis is done mostly
of women because quote,
the women were available to study because
they were at home during the day on
quote.
So what were the men consuming and what
were the children consuming when they
weren't at home and was there something
magical about this freak food frequency
questionnaire and these researchers
that they captured it accurately.
So this is what scientists, you
have studies, you have evidence in.
The question always is you've
got competing hypothesis.
Does this evidence really
speak to the hypothesis?
And I'm one of my issues with Steven,
it's what provoked aren't our initial
discord is that he's constantly citing
studies that don't actually,
either they only speak to one hypothesis
like the overfeeding study or they're
poorly constructed and poorly done.
So even this hazed example with the
honey is something we discussed an email
very kindly and we went
back and forth and I said,
I don't actually think it's a reputation
because the hypothesis I'm defending
here,
the case against sugar is you
add sugar to any populations,
native diet, and you get
epidemics of obesity and diabetes.
So here's a population that's been eating
honey for maybe thousands of years.
In fact,
when they emigrated to this area,
they may have added honey to their
diet and had obesity and diabetes.
Then in the Steven points out in the book,
obesity and diabetes in a
hunter gatherer populations,
a death sentence for the child and
for the mother who gives birth.
So you're going to very quickly
weed out anyone. So again,
it just comes back to this question
of does this actually does,
is it a refutation?
The hypothesis that I found
a hunter gatherer or a
population that eats a lot of
honey and is in fat. And the answer is I
don't think so. Stephen thinks it does.
You could flip a coin. All of this
can be settled with experiments.
One of the experiments we did it no city,
uh,
so one of the metabolic problems that
goes along with obesity and diabetes is
non alcoholic fatty liver disease.
It's endemic.
It used to be 20 years ago,
if he had alcoholic fatty,
if he had fatty liver disease,
a Dr. Wood and you told the
doctor you didn't smoke,
they would assume you were lying.
Now it's so common and
so common in children and
particularly common in Hispanic
children. They a that it's clear
it's not caused by alcohol.
And the question is what causes it?
Cause if you could create a fatty
liver with the macronutrient,
you could probably create
insulin resistance as well.
And then this whole slew of disorders
including obesity and diabetes.
So my non for profit funded a pilot
study where we just took 40 cared by the
researchers at UC San Diego and
at Emory university in Atlanta.
It took 40 kids who had nonalcoholic
fatty liver disease and randomized them
into two groups and one group.
We gave them the entire family,
all the food they need it so they
could overeat to their heart's extent,
but no added sugars in their
diet and no sugary beverages.
And this study was published in Jama
four months ago and it's just it
get rid of the sugar in the Diet. The
fatty liver disease resolves, you know,
it was pretty simple.
I could tells you nothing about mechanism.
The kids lost a little bit of weight.
Maybe it was a weight loss.
The conventional wisdom
would be they just ate less,
which I wouldn't be at all surprised
because they probably didn't like the food
as much without sugar in it.
But these are the kinds of ways you could
test these hypotheses and problems I
have with like the met analysis,
getting back to Kevin and hall,
there's two ways you could do science.
You could say,
let's look at all the junk that
was done for 30 40, 50 years.
Let's find everything we can.
That even vaguely speaks to the experiment
and ignore any quality of the study.
So if it may be asked,
it asks this question like we want to
know what happens when people do this.
But in doing this, we
switched there, you know,
fat intake around fat and carbon take
around and then we can throw all that
garbage into a Meta analysis.
And the one thing I'm pretty competent
as they did a poor job because of one
study I looked up the one with the biggest
effect they mistook Hila Jewel's for
kilocalories.
So they reported that 400 kilo calorie
decrease in energy expenditure on the low
fat diet and one was a 400 kilo joule,
which is, what's that factor? You know,
these numbers, uh, 0.8 0.18 or something.
Several of the other studies
where Jim Hill Studies,
we've talked about Jim how biggest studies
or Jen now and the way we approached
it, the non-for-profits say you've got
understand what the question is and you've
got to design an experiment
to get the right answer.
So when Stephen Dismiss
this Harvard three names for him now,
what Stephan's to fall his DNA,
right?
Dr Ghana, can I step to the named
Stephanie? It's really easy to find.
I can't do it. Do it. I just don't
get names. My name's Joe. All right,
Gary, that I know. I do the, um,
Stephan,
uh,
ultimately rejected this study is about
a $12 million study that was done at
Harvard based on Kevin Hall.
So these are two names.
It's about three people out there who
are convinced that everything people like
me are saying is wrong or not
everything but most of it.
And they keep coming up over
and over again. And they would,
so Kevin Hall claims that he has refuted
the carbohydrate insulin model in his
studies.
So when a study comes out supporting it,
he works to find out why that studies
wrong. We all did the same thing.
I did the same thing right here with the
Kuna study explaining why I don't find
it meaningful. But
anyway, that's the thing.
The goal was to do the right study cause
ultimately you got to remember what's
on the line here.
We have obesity and diabetes epidemics.
I mean tragic shit is going on out
there. I mean people, you know,
these are ruining lives. There are
overwhelming the healthcare system.
And the argument I made is
that for the past 50 years,
basically people have thought a lot like
Stephan is thinking now Dr Dna and that
there appears to be another story that
could be true and when we have to do is
find out if it is true
because people are dying now.
Stuff. Okay. Um,
the first thing I want to say is that
this alternative explanation that Gary is
talking about has already
been investigated intensively,
including studies that were
funded by his own organization,
new c two out of the three studies
that have been published on that.
We're clear reputations on
hypothesis and no, no, no.
I'm gonna responded here. No, no. I
know you've got to raise that the study,
correct. Gary, Gary, Gary,
I representing them according
to your beliefs is not
representing them correctly.
Okay.
Now I've noticed a remarkable correlation
between studies undermining your
beliefs and you thinking those studies
are garbage and we should talk about, uh,
Jim Hill and his studies a
little bit because, you know,
to me just saying this guy has a conflict
of interest and then insinuating that
that makes the study bad if you can't
actually find a problem with the study
itself. These were very rigorous
studies if you cannot point out,
I see the problem with the study,
it was designed with an assumption.
It was designed based on the assumption
it suppose it wasn't designed how Gary
wanted it to be designed.
Um,
if you cannot find a
problem with that study,
then you can't just dismiss it by making
these insinuations that the person had
a conflict of interest. Okay. I now into
the problem. Okay, that's great Gary.
Now Harry on it at the time.
All right.
You're going to be able to respond
in a moment. Now I'm the Cuna.
I think we should really get back to
this issue, this nonindustrial culture,
because the primary basis for Gary's book,
the case against sugar,
the primary observation
that underlies gears,
belief on this is this observational
correlational thing that cultures,
when sugar gets into these cultures,
they become fat and that is the
common thread and in obesity,
and so what I'm doing is I'm pointing
out a culture where sugar came in and it
did not make them fat and
that's one of three cultures.
I haven't even looked that hard.
Okay.
These are just three cultures that I
came across is probably a bunch more that
are eating high levels of sugar,
but they're 800 [inaudible] to our hobbies
and I think a is the same. And again,
Joe explanation is right on point.
There's a lot of other things going
on in these cultures and it's more
complicated than just sugar.
That's exactly my point.
Now I want to talk about
the Cuban economic crisis.
This is reference number 22 from 1989
through 1995 the Cuban economy collapsed
and the price of food went way up.
The price of gasoline went way up.
And so people started focusing
on these really cheap foods.
Cuba was a major sugar producer at the
time. I don't know if they still are.
And so the intake of sugar went way up.
Intake of refined
carbohydrate went way up.
The Diet became a 77% carbohydrate,
primarily white rice and sugar,
28% sugar of their total calorie intake.
So that's like double what Americans eat.
Now their calorie intake went down
and because of the lack of gasoline,
people got really physically active
because they had to walk everywhere.
So now again,
if this is,
this is a situation where we
can test Gary's hypothesis.
If Gary is right and
calories don't matter,
only refined carbohydrate
and sugar matter,
obesity should have gone through the roof
in this population over that period of
time.
What you actually see is that the
prevalence of obesity declined by half.
So there was a 50% decline.
It went from 14% to 7% over
the period of this. Um,
increase in sugar intake,
increase in refined carbohydrate intake.
And you might think,
well these people are just starving like
crazy and that's why obesity rate went
down. Well, we actually have evidence
on the rate of underweight as well.
And so we can check on that.
The rate of underweight
increased only slightly,
it went from 8% to 10%.
And so we know these people
weren't just totally starving. Um,
and what happened then
was as the Diet rebounded,
as the economy rebounded in the diet
rebounded and their diet shifted away from
these refined carbohydrates and sugar
and back to the normal diet that was
higher in, uh, in fats and lower
in carbohydrate, lower in sugar,
the obesity rate went right back up as
soon as they went back to their normal
diet. And so I find this cause there were,
there were not walking as much. Yeah,
I was an exercise and also just their
diet became richer again. I mean,
if you're eating a diet
that's a very poor diet,
eating like white rice and sugar,
I mean it,
it's not like if that's most of what if,
if you're sitting there and on your
plate is a white rice and sugar,
you're not going to be eating a ton of
that and getting fat as opposed to eating
a rich diet with more
varied foods. And so, um,
this is a case where you have an entire
country testing Gary's hypothesis and
finding that basically the opposite
of what his hypothesis predicts.
Yeah.
Uh, let's go with the, the, the,
when he was refuting the
studies and you want to go,
but this was a level of this course I
don't even really want to get into because
that's a study that I'm going
to have to read. He's right.
I'm gonna read it to try and
figure out what the problem is.
I remember looking at that study and
thinking there wasn't the kind of day to
your side and maybe there's
multiple studies put together,
but the one study I looked at, the kind
of day two you're citing wasn't in there.
That this is again a preferences are on
my website. So have at it. No I will,
but we'll be off the air by
then. Um, the beginning of his,
when he started talking,
who's referencing some studies
and you had a problem with that?
Well there's this whole, it's
a game. People plan again,
it's why basically in my
book I try not to get into,
he said she said studies cause
you never know how well they did.
I think we both agreed that there's
a reproducibility crisis in science.
It's some huge proportion of the
studies are just raw on whether their
experiments or observations.
People sometimes aren't
very good at what they do.
Right. And so anyone in either business,
you have to, Steven likes to say,
I have no evidence,
nothing dammit.
But simultaneously people accuse me of
writing a 600 page book with 150 pages of
references.
I was too long to read.
So there's clearly evidence for this
observation and this hypothesis.
My issue with Stephan
is had he speaks as though he knows
what this authority and so again,
I would like to just read a little bit
from your book because as I was prepping
for this, that was for
you do that though. The,
he was referencing Cuban situation.
I don't know what the reality for that.
Before that, when, when
you first started talking,
he was referencing things that you
were stating that he was saying.
What were you saying?
That uh, th th th the,
the organization that supports him
actually refuted Jim Hill Studies,
the Jim Hill, the, uh, the new c studies.
And now we're talking about the nuisance,
the first two of which, and we can
get, we can get into detail on this,
on how those refuted Gary's, uh, beliefs.
And I would say Gary is about the only
person who thinks that they did not
refuse just beliefs. The scientific
community is pretty unanimous,
can respond. But could you please say
what was, what would the study stayed on?
Let me do it before he did the first study
as a pilot study. That uh,
depends what you look at to depend
whether or not it refuted your beliefs.
So there again,
you have to understand this world.
There are researchers
who believe one thing,
Kevin Hall and Nih tends to believe that
obesity is an energy balance problem
and you people get fat because I ate too
much. I hope I'm doing Kevin Justice.
Um,
and then there's David Ludwig and his
colleagues at Harvard who tend to believe
what I believe and we funded them both
to do studies and Kevin Hall study.
Uh,
if you believe what Kevin,
if you believe Kevin
interpreted it correctly, uh,
was not supportive of this model,
that carbohydrates are ultimately driving
insulin and insulin is driving up fat
accumulation. And the
David Ludwig Study, uh,
reported the opposite.
And,
and David has criticized Kevin Study
and Kevin has criticized David study.
And this is the nature of science.
This is what you do in science.
You do an experiment, people critique
it. Ideally you do another one.
Kevin has decided, well, Kevin
is doing it. Another one,
I think he's asking the wrong questions,
but what I just saw the other day that
he's doing another experiment. Um,
today the middle study was a tree living
diet study where a done by Christopher
Gardner at Stanford University and the
idea was a original idea was 600 people
randomized to either a very
low carbohydrate diet or a
very low fat diet and we
funded it in part because we hoped that
Christopher would be able to get people
to almost a ketogenic diet
on that low carb side.
And Dean Ornish who promotes a low fat
diet always complained that the low fat
diet,
it wasn't fast enough so hopefully
they'd be able to separate out these two.
Um,
at the end of the trial they
got pretty lousy adherence.
A low carb was about 25 to 28% carb,
which is by no means a low meaning,
pretty typical,
pretty typical in free living studies.
And the low fat was about equal. Um,
what they did,
which it's funny,
we've analyzed this on one
side but not the other. Um,
they told the low carb group not
to eat sugars and refined grains,
which are by my hypothesis the
most fattening carbohydrates.
And they also told the low fat group to
Nati refined sugars and refined grains.
So they basically removed
the most fattening parts of
the Diet from both arms of
the study.
It's funny,
we knew that we're going to do with
the low carb group cause you have to,
and my colleagues actually knew they
were going to do with the low fat group.
I didn't know that.
When I found out I was stunned
because now you're testing two diets.
Neither one of them have
sugar or white bread.
So now you see similar weight loss
with relatively poor compliance.
Why would they do that? That doesn't
make any sense with the argument. And we,
we talked to Chris for
a lot of his argument.
He was afraid there were two things on,
he wanted the Diet to be healthy. Okay.
So a healthy diet in 2015 has become a
diet that doesn't have sugar and white
bread in it.
So he wasn't going to promote sugar and
white bread to one died or the nother,
um, I take so long as the period of time
where they're studying these people,
they were on the die. They were supposed
to be on the Diet for a year. Okay.
That makes sense. Yeah. So
that's the question is again,
would you expect to see a difference?
I can send you an email I wrote to my new
see colleagues in 2015 I could read it
when I found out about this low fat thing
saying this is insane. He's removed.
They both groups are
carbohydrate restricted.
So you could think of it as a low fat
carbohydrate restricted diet and a high
fat carbohydrate restricted diet.
And then he kinda got the same answer,
which could be for any reason
whatsoever. There's a paper, uh,
I don't know if I can, well,
I'm not going to talk about,
it's bad enough talking about ambiguous
studies that have been published without
getting into, on published research. But,
so people see this, the New York Times,
for instance, the two stories on it. One
of them said it's not about calories.
It's about the quality,
the sugar in there,
fine grain because both groups restricted
sugar and refined grains and loss
weight the other.
And that was written by a reporter
who tends to believe what we believe.
And the other article said,
it's all about the calories because both
groups ended up on average eating 500
calories each at the end up.
From a scientific perspective
being a poorly done study,
even though we funded it, I'm not, it's
just, it didn't answer the question.
You said 500 calories each.
500 heritage valley strict Calvinist
actually self reported. So it's not,
so it's not particularly meaningful. So
again, these are, I don't like using,
it's a complicated study
because it's low in sugar.
Well and it's also free living.
Yeah. So both sides are low in sugar.
Both sides are not eating processed to
full differences in total carbohydrate
intake.
Okay.
So even though they were both not
eating as much refined carbohydrate,
they were still too full differences or
greater over the period of that study in
total carbohydrate into,
if you believe the food frequency
questionnaires that you just said,
we don't know whether we have a, well
you could be talking about vegetables,
you could be talking about fruits.
Well these are healthy carbohydrates
that they had primarily in this study.
Can we right now we agree that that study
can be interpreted from virtually any
way you want it.
Especially because it was a free living.
You don't agree with that. Um,
now, now what we will agree on,
I'll agree with you on this,
is that refined carbohydrates and
sugar are the most fattening type of
carbohydrate that we can agree on
what God, we came to an agreement.
But the question then the question is
why is it because people eat too much of,
here's the thing. If you, if
you believe Gary hypothesis now,
any kind of carbohydrate
increases insulin levels.
Some do it more than others are
fine carbohydrates do it more.
Any kind of carbohydrate increases
insulin levels relative to fat. Okay.
And so if that is true and these
groups and that matters for fat loss,
these groups had two full
differences in carbohydrate intake.
Even though it was predominantly healthy
carbs, you would just shoot a scene,
something you shouldn't have seen the
exact same amount of weight loss in these
two groups. Right? Right. But
they're not high in sugar,
but present your argument is always there.
Part of the argument,
which is you take away the sugar and
that was the problem with one of the
problems with the ANA. Yeah. The
argument I'm making and and stuff,
it's completely right and I'm
defending my hypothesis. Okay,
I see a study that he does the same
thing. He did it here. We all do it.
You see a study that disagrees with you.
You find the reason why I did not believe
it in every study ever done has plenty
of reasons not to do
and not to believe it.
That's why independent replication is
something you always wanted to get another
group to do the study. Ideally
a third group, people come in,
they criticized the study, then you'd
do it again and again and again. And so,
you know what I was trying,
when we,
even when we started the
nutrition science initiative,
the choice stem is a nonprofit.
The choice of the word initiative was to
get nutrition researchers to an effect
s stop using these garbage,
poorly designed studies to
come to conclusions because
they like or dislike the
interpretation,
but try to get them to think the way
harder scientists would and developing
studies that it asks precisely
the right question. And then the,
so even the pilot study that
was interpreted as not supporting
this hypothesis, and again,
you could argue that for an
hour and nobody's going to care.
That study was not randomized.
So non randomized study,
you can't infer causality.
It's that's why it was a pilot study.
One of the many reasons
it was a pilot study.
The people who think
this carbohydrate model.
So I think when we talk about
the carbohydrate incident model,
it means carbohydrates are fattening.
That's the basis of it. Bread, pasta,
potato and sugar may be the,
the thing that's necessary to add to
the Diet to make all these carbs fat and
then cause sugar. As we talked
about this a year and a half ago,
the fructose molecule is
metabolized in the liver.
It's linked to fat accumulation in
the liver, which is linked to insulin.
And I like the way you're squeezing your
stomach fat while we're talking about
that matter. I got to work out dude. Um,
the uh, just boring, you know,
for these experiments to be done right
there, they have to be tested, right?
Like you can't use pork poorly designed
experiments of poorly, you know,
and every experiment ever done.
And so what we've tried to do is keep
working towards better experiments.
There's now a new version of the Ludwick
experiment being done at the Arnold
Foundation.
Laura and John Arnold funded to the tune
of I think 13 bill million dollars and
whatever that study fines Kevin Hall
and we'll probably find the reason,
look in it and find a reason to question.
And ideally they would be working
together so that you come up with the
criticisms before you've spent $13
million, but this is how science works.
My job was to tell a good
story is Stephanie would say,
and I believe people who read the books
can judge whether they're too good.
You know, am I convincing in arguing
that the you add sugar to it,
counter evidence to everything.
There wasn't counter evidence and wouldn't
require a journalist to come along in
20 whatever it is,
19 lip to make these arguments you this
because this is something that you've
admitted to something you said rather.
Why are sugary carbohydrates
the most fattening?
Well,
if this hypothesis is correct,
I think s you would say that they
trigger our food reward or they are,
wait,
let me just finish and I would say the
counter argument is that they create a
hormonal milieu in the body that that
over responds to insulin and insulin.
Well we haven't said is if you look in
a textbook for fat metabolism and fatty
and you know what causes fat storage,
insulin is the hormone that
primarily regulates fat storage.
In your fat tail.
So the idea is that you raise insulin
and the sugar because of this path of it
being fructose and that mostly being
metabolized in the small intestine in the
liver seems may indeed
cause insulin resistance.
And if it does you over respondents.
And so one is a peripheral explanation,
not that people don't love it and they
don't want to, you know, over consume it,
whatever that means.
And the other is a central explanation.
Yeah. So I mean sugar is a factor that
makes us want to eat foods, right?
I mean this is one of the many food
properties I would love to talk about this
more.
That caused dopamine release in the brain.
And dopamine is a chemical that sets
our motivational levels to do certain
behaviors.
So the reason we become addicted to drugs
is that they go in the brain and they
stimulate dopamine release and that
reinforces drug seeking behaviors. Right?
But this is just causing you
to consume more. Correct.
But you're saying that the actual amount,
let's say if you have the same amount of
carbohydrates are sugary carbohydrates
versus the same amount that our vegetable,
carbohydrates,
it sugary carbohydrates are going
to be more fattening? No, no,
I didn't say it was
independently of calories.
It's still entirely dependent
on calories. Yeah, correct.
And we have randomized controlled
trials, um, demonstrating that.
So if you look at the randomized
there, by the way, we're not, uh,
we're not operating in an evidence vacuum.
There's tons of randomized controlled
trials on sugar. These random,
these randomized controlled
studies, are they short term? Um,
it depends. Well, it depends on how you
define short term. They're not last time,
years and years isn't the issue though.
Longterm chronic effects like
that seems to be possibly,
but let me put it this way. You know, if
you believe that insulin is the cause,
the effect of insulin on fat
cells happens almost immediately.
So Insulin,
I,
I'm not aware of any mechanism of insulin
on fat cells that takes more than a
few hours to occur. And so if you
believe that insulin causes obesity,
this should be happening immediately.
You shouldn't have to wait months
and months for this to occur. No,
that doesn't make any sense at all.
No, it does make sense. It makes sense.
It makes sense. You eat, you
eat. Does that make sense
to you? Well, because again,
he's, he's kind of making this up
as he goes along. So the idea is
we'll explain why it doesn't make sense
without consulting us as possible.
Has he not been insulting me ever? I
might just buy us. I realized that I,
it's everything is perspective but
necessarily saying he's insulting your
stories, not you personally, but
what, what, what do you, what,
why doesn't it make sense
to you? Okay. So the idea is
when your insulin is elevated,
you're storing fat, right? Uh,
it depends on what you mean by that.
That's not,
see you do a little bit
of Bait and switch here.
That's an intouch is to answer the
question. If it's well, it depends.
What do you mean by store?
I mean your fat cells are accumulating
fat when insulin is element.
Do you mean accumulate? Like,
like next day you'll have to fat.
It inhibits, uh, uh,
yeah, that's incorrect.
It stimulates lipid protein lipase and
it inhibits hormone sensitive. We should,
we should really talk about this because
that's incorrect. It's in the textbook.
No. Yeah. We'll talk about what's in the
textbook. Don't worry Gary. They do says,
um,
okay so you don't believe it,
but just give me your position and
then I'll let him refute it. Uh,
it's here but just say it. Just
want to show it. Okay. Cause again,
you're going to say it's not in here.
So I have the same textbook
and then we'll let Joe here.
Suppression of Fat
Mobilization by Insulin.
And there's another graph that is
a stimulation of fat mobilization.
Congratulations to all of you people
that are listening to this [inaudible]
hanging in there.
I know we're in the weird scientific,
let me just say this is
going to take a long time.
So we agree on the molecular mechanisms.
Okay.
We agree on the molecular mechanisms,
the impact of insulin on
enzymes and fat cells.
What we disagree about is
the implications of that.
And I think that's what
we should talk about.
It's true because nowhere in that textbook
does it say that insulin regulates
the total size of body fat stores.
Absolutely guarantee that is that is
something that chemo have added onto that
mechanism. Would you like
to know conversation I have
with the author of, no,
not right now actually.
So, um, the now the,
now let me tell you about the
conversation. Actually Gary, let me,
and I should explain this for,
we talked for three hours.
Can you stop interrupting me please?
Okay,
now let me explain.
So insulin essentially does have effects
on enzymes that cause fat cells to take
up more fat and to release less fat. So
that's the part that you're right about.
That's what that textbook talks about.
Now that does not mean that does not imply
that insulin causes fat storage as in
the accumulation of fat from day to day.
And let me explain why that is.
So insulin is basically a traffic cop
that allows your body to burn the fuel
that you just consumed.
So when you eat a diet that's high
in carbohydrate and low in fat,
your insulin goes up, your body restricts
the fat from going out of fat cells.
It turns that down,
not off but down.
It causes less fat to come out of your
fat cells and then your body's burning
carbs.
That's what you just ate right now.
If you eat a diet that's high in
fat and lower in carbohydrate,
you secrete less insulin.
Those effects don't occur on your fat
cells and that allows your body to burn
the fat that you just ate.
But at the end of the day,
the amount of fat that you have in
your body is the amount that you,
eight minus the amount that you burned.
That's what determines the amount.
This is just arithmetic,
right amount that you eight minus the
amount that you burned and if you eat a
low fat diet, you're not eating
much and you're not burning much.
You're in the same place as if you're
eating a diet where you're eating a lot of
fat and burning a lot of fat.
And the way we know that's true is
because varying the amount of carbohydrate
and fat in the Diet makes no difference
to body fatness in randomized controlled
trials. So I know that what I
just said is correct. No. So the,
first of all, it's one
randomized controlled trial.
Which Kevin Hall or gamma? No,
I'm talking about a Meta analysis
of randomized controlled trials to
meta-analyses. We decided
that, I think that the, Oh,
what's wrong with men analysis from it?
He doesn't like crappy study ever done.
He doesn't like who did it basically.
No, no, no, no. I don't care who does it.
I don't like men analyses.
I don't like the concept of am.
I think it's one of the problems with
modern nutritional and medical sciences.
You do crappy studies generate garbage
and then you sift through the and say,
I can find
a truth in here. And the answer
is do better. Studies, answers,
always do better studies you
can't do, yeah, Med analyses,
they exist for everything.
The issue was just as a simple,
and remember we're talking
about the 10 calories a day.
So when you said the difference between
the fat burned and the fat store or the
fat consumed in the fat expand
that has to be 10 calories a day.
That's that's what we're talking about.
10 calories in the fat tissue.
Okay.
So if it is true that if I consume 1500
calories a day and I somehow metabolizer
excrete 1490,
and I guarantee that no such
study was ever so carefully done,
the support this, uh,
well you could think of,
you're sensing the energy
balanced consortium study,
the Kevin Hall study that we've
talked about. One of the things,
there are two things that happened when
you put people on a ketogenic diet,
among other things,
you generate ketones and you lose
ketones in the breadth and in the urine.
And one of the things you have to do
in these energy balance experiments is
measure calories loss through
fecal material. Who knows,
maybe you jack up the fat consumption.
Maybe they lose more fat
calories when they shit it out.
Or maybe you set up the
five calories matter.
I think when you're measuring the fat
balance, which you're talking about,
you have to measure the
amount of fat in and out.
And so I'm giving you an
example in response to your
question was could you give
me an example in that study, they
didn't do either of those measurements.
They modeled one and the other one,
they couldn't get the,
the assay to work after a year
or two years and gave up on it.
And so you just don't know.
But getting back to this question,
we're talking about somebody's storing
10 calories of fat and their fat cells,
let's never get away from that or 20
calories. And so the question is always,
is this mechanism,
uh,
capable of explaining the
20 calories or is the,
what did you find him
looking in that book? Well,
it's essentially what he was saying and
then sun inhibits fat mobilization from,
well, I can read it if you want me to
read it. You know, I mean, but I mean,
Gary and I both agree with
what's in that textbook.
You can read it if you want it.
Restraints,
fat mobilization through two mechanisms.
So suppression of light light policies,
is that, what was that
right, yeah. Life policy.
So mechanisms are described in the
text and the stimulation of the re
esterification of fatty
acids within the ad,
a ad,
a pile as dining site at depth
insights at depth depth fat cells.
Note that the same process of uh,
esterification we'll
also be simultaneously
incorporated fatty acids from
circulating tri glycerol.
Glycerides. Yeah. Uh,
triacylglycerol triacylglycerol
triacylglycerol right.
Released by lipid protein.
Lipos
land pays limb pays enough.
Joe [inaudible] piece. Yeah.
L I p a s e a into stored
try ass soul glycerol.
Yeah. So let me explain
this briefly. Big words.
The argument I've been making and others
is that insulin inhibits fat loss.
If you're a fat cell and you see
insulin, you hold onto your fat, right?
It's kind of that simple. Stephan's
absolutely right. This book, which is,
we're talking about, is it metabolic
regulation of human perspective?
It's written by Keith Frane,
who's retired.
Oxford professor is a wonderful man and
he was the world's leading authority on
metabolic regulation.
How your body controls its use of fuel
and orchestrates storage and oxidation.
And in this book,
Keith Frane talks about how insulin
determines fat accumulation and fat cells.
And this is the accumulation,
whatever, fat storage, fat storage,
fat try NAMIC fatty acid trafficking
in and out of fat cells. Okay,
thank you.
So the first time I ever interviewed
Keith was for a piece I was doing for the
journal Science on a insulin resistance.
And we spent about an hour on the phone
and he explained to me for 20 minutes
all the ways insulin
traps the Turmans fatty acid trafficking
across the fat cell membrane.
And you raise until then you will
accumulate more fat on the short term.
And then we got to obesity and they said,
well be cities, you know, caused by a
people eating too much. And
I said, Keith, when we were
talking about why fat cells get
fad was all insulin mediated.
And when we were talking about people get
fad, it was this eating too much thing.
Okay.
And you switched mechanisms on me.
So my assumption is the same reason people
get fat as the same reason their fat
cells get fat.
And you've got a whole lot of,
you've got this disorder metabolic
syndrome we're talking about,
which includes not just uh,
uh,
yeah,
problems with your blood lipids,
but it includes getting fat
or your waistline increasing.
And it's an insulin
resistance related disorder,
which means your insulin is elevated.
And again,
this is where we end up with two
hypotheses about why insulin is elevated.
But if the friends and sugar can elevate
insulin and you end up with metabolic
syndrome,
you're in fat storage mode.
That's the terminology
of Diet book doctors.
So now you're storing fat and
only have to do 10 calories a day,
20 calories a day,
you're going to get obese.
And it's insulin mediate and insolence
responding to the carbohydrate content of
the Diet primarily. And that's it. And
when I said this to Keith, you know,
you've got one mechanism for white fat
cells get fat and a different mechanism
for why humans get fat. And I'd like
to talk about this over eating concept.
Um, he said, you know, I
never thought of that. I mean,
the guy had been in the field 40 years
and he let them maybe 50 and then I had a
long conversation with him.
I was back in Oxford when I did
that insane Alan Aragon debate.
I stopped off at Oxford on the way to
Manchester and we had a long conversation
with Keith. I said, look,
what I want you to do is just
come up with a hypothesis of obesity
from the fat cells perspective,
right?
Shed your brain centric energy balance
centric thing and ask yourself what does
the fat cell c and if nothing else asked
a student to do it as an experiment.
I mean that would be a great
thought experiment for kid.
What's going to make a fat cell fat
and that our assumption is going to be
that's what's going to make a
human fat. Okay. And Keith said,
he literally said to me, he was retiring
and he was going off to garden. Um,
I kind of envied him, but
he said, no, I just can't,
I can't put energy balance aside.
You're telling me to not think in terms
of it's been taken expenditure and I
can't do it. And I mean
wonderful man. He literally,
and this is again what I've been
arguing is all these people are soap,
including Stephen who was, you know,
who learned in this world. They're,
they're so locked into this thinking
that obesity is this energy imbalance and
they can't get away from it. So everything
they do, everything they interpret.
And when Stephen says there's study
after study and there's 20 randomized
control studies and it's
sort of, I'm going to shovel
the evidence on top of you.
And I'm saying, look, I guarantee
if we go through those 20 studies,
I'll be just like the Jim Hill study.
They assumed energy balance was the
cause and then they wanted to see what
caused energy imbalance. And they
started with the wrong hypothesis.
They're trapped in a paradigm. We've all
seen this. Can I respond to this? Okay.
So,
uh, Gary, I preordered your book. I
have a copy of your book right here.
Good calories,
bad calories.
I preordered this in 2008 because I
was so excited to read this book. Yes.
And will email me.
I tore through it and I was so persuaded
when I initially read this 10 years ago
that I ate a low carbohydrate diet
for six months cause I thought I was,
I thought the carbs, we're going to
make me fat and give me diabetes.
So I was fully immersed and convinced by
your perspective when I read this book.
Yeah. And you and you sign this
book, you see I have your signature.
We had a very nice dinner together and
the thing that caused me to go away from
that perspective was when I actually
started investigating the evidence on my
own underlying these ideas.
I started doing my own research.
I didn't take your word for it.
I started doing my own research in the
lab as well and actually doing real
scientific studies.
But what you are standing and found that
it did not line up with what you were
saying in your book. And what I ended
up realizing about good calories,
bad calories
is essentially your arguments primarily
rely on historical narratives and
speculation.
And there's very little of actually saying
what is the most pertinent scientific
evidence to answer this question.
And what does that evidence have to say?
It's mostly historical narratives.
And honestly, you know, I'm,
I'm going to try to say this
in in a non insulting way,
but I will simply say that others who
have looked at the same historical
evidence have come to different
conclusions then you have. Um,
and that includes me in the places where
I've looked at the historical evidence.
And so, um, I think that, you know,
this idea that I am like locked in
some paradigm and can't see what you're
talking about. I was there
Gary. I am posting. Yeah,
let me then, okay, so let
me, let me, let me just,
it was interesting cause you're
going to wrap this up soon.
So we've really gone there
three hours almost. Um,
remember when you drove up here from San
Diego this morning and I was listening
to Stephan on a different podcast and
you were talking about how your eating
behavior differed on low carb diets
versus the higher carb diet you eat now.
And you talked about your resistance,
it was easier to fast on the
low carb diet. Correct. Okay.
And you didn't really have
an explanation for it.
I don't have a very well anyway,
go ahead. Yeah, so again,
the argument I've been making is this,
there's two ways to look at everything.
So one way is the low carb
diet, somehow the, because of,
I don't food reward his shoes
affects your urge to eat
car and low carb foods.
And because of that you don't
hunger for them as much. And uh,
when you're on a higher carb diet,
I think the way you phrased on and start
the podcast was your body sort of tells
you what to meal time.
So it's conditioned to me better.
So the alternative hypothesis here,
the other way to think about it is on the
low carb diet isn't insulin levels are
staying lower.
And when they're saying lower,
he's mobilizing fat and
he's oxidizing that fat.
And as you said on the podcast,
and have you been, uh, you know,
the 135 pound marathon or has enough
fat in this body to run for a week.
So the reason you're able to skip
meals is because insulin is low fuel.
My wife is calling, she's probably
telling me I'm getting shrill. Um,
there's a different way
to look at everything.
That's the point I'm trying
to put every study. I mean,
tell me evidence that,
can you give me actual evidence that the
lower level of insulin is the cause of
not needing to use
his meals? No. Okay. I'm giving you a high
palm. Glad you're being all gamuts. No,
that's what you're saying. Like we
were talking about fasting, right?
If you're fasting for a certain
prolonged period of time,
your body's going to go into a ketogenic
state. We all agree with that. Right?
And that's,
that's the reason why it's easier to fast.
Once you're in key to genic states,
your body starts burning off fat and this
is a widely reported that's living on
fat. It's metabolically flexible.
You don't have date cause,
but it's the idea that it's living on
your fat is evidence that you're getting
thinner on that low carb diet is,
it's that balance.
It's the amount of your eating
minus the amount your burn now,
but it's a question as it's tossed with
the amount you're trapping and that's
what you keep leaving out.
So if you have no,
that has been tested is what I'm saying.
It has not been tested. That's what
I'm saying. That's why we founded Nusi.
That's why we spent $30 million.
That's why David Ludwig is doing
another $13 million starting.
It has not been tested. When
you, when you feed people,
whether it's overfeeding or underfeeding
and you're causing weight loss or
weight maintenance, the carb to fat ratio
of the Diet makes almost no different.
Me Give you another many studies on this
famous feeding study from the 60s which
I thought when you said Horton, I
thought you meant Ed Hort, not Tj Horton.
So at Horton and Ethan Sims at a
prisoner study, they literally,
they wanted to get the overfeed.
Again,
they're using their thinking
in terms of eating too much.
They wanted to get first get college
kids to gain 25% of excess body weight.
This was in the 60s and they couldn't
get the college kids to do it,
which suggests that college kids were
different in the 60s and they are today.
So they used prisoners in the Vermont
state prison and they overfed them.
And you discuss this in your book.
Um,
they could get these prisoners to
eat 10,000 calories a day of excess
carbohydrates,
excess calories.
It was calories, not carbohydrate,
might've been calories.
They couldn't get them to add more
than a thousand calories of fat. Okay.
And they talk about this,
Sim studies were crazy cause they
published in 15 different journals.
So they interpret the study.
If you looked at pounds gained,
okay
per calorie added,
they gained more per calorie of fat
than they did per calorie of carbs.
But if you looked at
how much they could eat,
they couldn't add that much fat and they
could add eight thousand seven thousand
extras calories of carbs in.
It's actually a line in one of the papers
when they said they would eat 10,000
calories and then go to bed hungry,
craving more carbs.
So then the question becomes,
again,
is it because the carbs are
doing something in the brain
to increase food reward
or is it the carbs are doing something
in the body so that their body has
figured out a way it can orchestrate
deal with this massive influx of carbs
versus fat.
But there's always two ways to look at it.
And every time Stephen says
there's masses of evidence,
my job as a journalist
was to go through and say,
does this refute that hypothesis? And
if it doesn't, we have to hold onto it.
Because remember we have an obesity and
diabetes epidemic and the kind of advice
where we tell people to sleep better
and eat less or avoid
foods that they love,
don't have pizza and ice cream.
It's implies that the reason they get fat,
even the overeating and hypothesis,
you think they should be eating pizza
and cream? What do you think? Uh, no,
I think we would both say don't eat pizza
and I don't ask questions like that.
Thank you. Um, the, uh,
is something wrong out there? Tragically
wrong. We know. If nothing else,
I think you would agree with us. So
the whole low carb movement, it's,
you set it on this podcast was that, you
know what I've done, if nothing else,
as I've convinced people,
they could eat low carb diets
without killing themselves.
So that's a good thing.
And I'm implying that I assume what
the sugar book, even if I'm wrong,
that getting people to eat
less sugar is a good thing.
So ultimately these are good things
that I've done. My overall really, Gary,
not entirely because you're telling
people that only carbohydrate matters.
I'm not telling Halleran table hardware.
You have argued at length.
I in calorie intake and dietary fat
intake and physical activity do not
influenced body fatness and are not
important for your with your ex the wrong
way. I'm arguing that. No,
if you're going to look at the model
that we published that you contributed to
and we signed off on,
it doesn't say anything about
physics says that physical activity,
dietary fat intake and calorie
and take are not important.
Refuse that.
Somebody who's on Scott that way
because they were sedentary. Okay, okay.
Requires,
but what I'm saying is that there is
harm in what you're saying because yes,
we all agree that these
carbohydrates are fattening.
But you're saying that these other
important things are irrelevant and that's
the dangerous part of what you're saying.
No,
what I'm saying about calories is it's
the wrong way to think about it. So wait,
you think they do matter?
I chained calories or the wrong.
Don't put words in went.
Okay. Do they matter?
Do calories matter our way to measure
the quantity of food you're eating?
It could use grams. You could use anything
else that you want. The question is,
is it the right way to think about it?
Can you solve an obesity?
Let me give you an example before we go.
Let me just read.
So excess calorie intake and physical
inactivity or secondary to this process
and not themselves determinants of
body fat. That is what you said.
Fine in our, uh, can I read you
some debate notes? Okay. That's,
I'm not putting words in your mouth.
You just want to read that yet,
but that's different than what
you just tried. Okay, sure
it is. They're just, okay.
Let me read you something.
They just never seem to be enough
food to sift shade Carl's growing body
afterschool.
You would need a footlong sub before
his mother's home cooked dinners.
Even after having a hefty
lunch of homemade chicken,
rice and vegetables and his favorite
snacks, granola bars and bunch or crunch.
Okay. A lot of calories and
a lot of them are one person.
We are talking about what we, yeah. How
is this going to, I just want to know,
just one of my colleagues
has one anecdotal,
one of my problems with the hoe over
eating hypothesis is it's taught to
logical. You don't know if someone's
overeating unless they're fat.
Right? Uh, incorrect. Well, this fellow,
I just read your calorie
intake and you can know, well,
wait a second about there Gary.
We would eat a footlong sub before
it's mother's home cooked dinners.
Even after having a half the lunch of
homemade chicken, rice and vegetables.
Again, that's one story, but the
point is, my point is it's like
you cannot tell if someone's fat.
I,
you have no idea how many
calories I consume. Right.
I could probably get a pretty decent
estimate actually based on a published
formulas. Okay. So, and then how would
you know whether I was overeating?
Remember we're talking about 10
calories get stored in the fat tissue.
Well that depends on whether you
meet, how you define that. But um, I,
I could look at your body composition
and I could tell you whether you are over
eating relative to a lean person. Yes.
Because I have excess body fat. Correct.
Yeah. So without knowing
if I have excess body fat,
you cannot tell whether I'm overeating,
which is the cause of the excess body fat.
Right?
Doesn't that strike you as circular?
There's nothing circular about it. Look,
if you take somebody and you increase
their calorie intake, carbs or fat,
either way, the gain, body fat,
there's nothing circular on it.
I'm not saying that calories in choice
body pretty confident that the fellow,
and if you take someone who is currently
has obesity and you reduced their
calorie intake, carbs or fat doesn't
make any difference, they lose body fat.
There's nothing circular
about this calorie thing at
all. It does make it, no, no,
I just, I don't understand how you
could possibly think that was circular.
It's so simple and direct.
Let me go through it one more time.
No, listen, you're not going
through anything. One more time.
We're going to wrap this up cause I don't
think we're getting anything done here.
Uh, it was a lot of fun.
It was that much fun.
It was, it was interesting.
I mean there's, I,
I don't know who to believe
quite honestly. I think, uh,
you both make some excellent points and a,
I think there's definitely some real
legitimate concern that you have about his
position. And I think that your
position, it has some merit as well,
the position about insulin and
about carbohydrates and sugar. Um,
this is a really long conversation and
I think we could probably do this for
another six days. Forget
about hours. Uh, I think, uh,
if I would recommend people,
I think people have to really kind
of figure this out for themselves.
I would recommend, uh, Stefan,
please recommend your book.
What is your book again?
The book is called the hungry, very hungry
brain and it's available everywhere.
Amazon, all that jazz. And uh, Gary,
yeah,
it's a good calories,
bad calories or why we get
fat or the case against sugar.
I think we've just begun this debate.
I don't think I'm going on a lot of
evidence here that I didn't have time to
site, unfortunately. Yeah. Well, it was a
long one, but thank you gentlemen. Thank
you. All right. Thank you Joe.